Hi you guys. Hello. Hello. We are on our winter break, but we wanted to pop on and wish you guys a happy holidays. Yes, happy holidays, everybody. And Jenna, what? I have a little bit of a Christmas craft bragg. Are you saying bragg or bag? Do you have a Christmas craft bag or? No. Okay, first of all, listen, maybe I should have picked a better choice of words. It's kind of hard to say. A Christmas bragg or bag? A Christmas crafting bragg. I have something to brag about in the crafting world that is Christmas. Oh, begin bragg. Please begin bragg. My Christmas craft bragg. I made a wreath for my front door. Of course you did. Lady, it was so fun. It wasn't that hard. I got some old cardboard and I cut like into a circle and then I wrapped ribbon around it. And then I got some of our older ornaments. You know, you have some sad ornaments that you've held on to, but you don't want to get rid of them. Well, I glued them all in a circle and I made a wreath. It kind of looks like a third grader did it, but you know what? The kids love it and I hung it on the front door. That is adorable. Thank you. You know, my secret wish is to have a really mediocre crafting show. Like anyone, anyone who's like, I can't do that, Martha Stewart, you're crazy. I'm going to go over to crappy crafting with Kinsey. I imagine you like you've got your glass of rose and your glue gun. Yeah. And you're doing like this amazing kind of like half-assed crafting job. Oh, no, it's fully half-assed. Am I getting it right? It's fully half-assed. I just want friends to come over and drink wine and do crappy crafting. That's my show. We're starting this show in the new year. 100%. Look forward on YouTube, Crappy Crafting with Kinsey. I'm there. Well, listen, lady, this makes sense because we actually come from a very long line of crafters. Your mom is amazing. I mean, we've talked about her quilting. She's incredible.
大家好。你好。你好。我们正在过寒假，但我们想上来祝大家节日快乐。是的，节日快乐，各位。杰娜，什么？我有一件关于圣诞手工艺品的炫耀。你是说炫耀（bragg）还是包（bag）？你有一个圣诞手工艺包还是？没有。好吧，首先，听着，也许我应该选个更好的词。这有点难说。一个圣诞炫耀还是包？一个圣诞手工艺炫耀。在手工艺界，我有值得炫耀的东西，而且是关于圣诞节的。哦，开始炫耀吧。请开始炫耀吧。我的圣诞手工艺炫耀。我给我的前门做了一个花环。你当然会这么做。天哪，太有趣了。没那么难。我拿了一些旧纸箱，剪成圆圈状，然后把丝带缠在上面。接着我找了一些我们以前的旧装饰品。你知道的，总有一些你舍不得扔、一直留着的伤感装饰品。好吧，我把它们都粘成一个圆圈，做成了一个花环。看起来有点像三年级学生做的，但你知道吗？孩子们很喜欢，我把它挂在了前门上。太可爱了。谢谢。你知道，我内心的秘密愿望是办一个非常平庸的手工艺秀。就像任何人，任何觉得自己“做不到，玛莎·斯图尔特，你疯了”的人。我要去金西的劣质手工艺秀。我能想象你拿着一杯桃红葡萄酒和一把热熔胶枪的样子。是的。然后你做那种惊人的、半吊子的手工艺活。哦，不，这是完全的半吊子。我理解对了吗？这是完全的半吊子。我只是想让朋友们过来喝红酒，做做劣质手工艺品。这就是我的节目。我们在新的一年里要开办这个节目。百分之百。敬请期待YouTube上的“金西的劣质手工艺秀”。算我一个。听着，女士，这说得通，因为我们实际上有着悠久的手工艺人血统。你妈妈太棒了。我是说，我们谈过她的拼布被。她太不可思议了。
But every year she sends me something homemade that she's made. Yes, she makes homemade Christmas ornaments. She makes these little Christmas trees out of recycled denim. She's super crafty. She's not, she is not crappy crafty. She's super good crafty. Well, and then we've talked about how my dad is an amazing builder. And this year, out of wood, he made a little sunny cat wearing a Santa hat. You're kidding me. No, I'm not kidding you. And he made a Christmas tree out of wine corks. Oh, my dad and your mom need to start an Etsy store. They do. And they also need to be guests on crappy crafting. Well, listen, let's get to this week's episode. It is one of our very favorites. It's season two Christmas party. Yes. And we thought, you know, for some of you guys who are new to the podcast, this was one of our favorite episodes. It's got everything. It's got the party planning committee, Yankee Swap, and of course the teapot. I do talk a lot about the teapot, don't I? You do. Well, you guys have a wonderful holiday. We are, you know, crafting and drinking wine and eating in sweatpants. That's right. And we will see you in the new year. But let's get to it. Christmas party. Let's do it. I'm Jenna Fisher.
但她每年都会寄给我一些她亲手制作的homemade东西。是的，她制作自制的圣诞装饰品。她用回收的牛仔布做这些小圣诞树。她超级心灵手巧。她不是，她绝不是手艺差。她手艺超级好。然后我们谈过我爸爸是个了不起的建筑工人。今年，他用木头做了一个戴着圣诞老人帽子的可爱小猫。你在开玩笑吧。不，我没开玩笑。他还用红酒瓶塞做了一棵圣诞树。哦，我爸爸和你妈妈应该去开一家Etsy网店。他们确实应该。而且他们也应该去“劣质手工艺秀”当嘉宾。好了，听着，让我们进入本周的剧集。这是我们最喜欢的剧集之一。它是第二季的圣诞派对。是的。我们想，对于一些刚接触播客的朋友来说，这绝对是我们最喜欢的剧集之一。它应有尽有。有派对策划委员会、白象礼品交换，当然还有茶壶。我确实经常谈论那个茶壶，对吧？你确实经常说。好了，祝大家度过一个美好的假期。我们呢，你知道的，穿着运动裤做手工、喝红酒、吃东西。没错。我们新的一年见。但我们言归正传吧。圣诞派对。开始吧。我是杰娜·菲舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everyone. Ho, ho, ho.
我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好，吼，吼，吼。
This is a big episode. It's the Christmas episode. It's the Christmas episode. The very first Christmas episode of The Office. Season two, episode 10. You know, it's not, we call it the Christmas episode. Yeah, we do. Or Christmas episode, but it is technically called Christmas party. What? Yeah, that's the name of this episode. I don't believe you.
这是一集大制作。这是圣诞特辑。这是圣诞特辑。《办公室》的第一集圣诞特辑。第二季，第十集。你知道，这不是，我们叫它圣诞特辑。是的，我们是这么叫的。或者叫圣诞集，但它的官方剧名其实叫“圣诞派对”。什么？对，这就是这集的剧名。我不信。
Christmas party. I don't believe you. No, I'm kidding. We did. We call it, we call it the Christmas episode. We call it the Christmas episode, even though there were many more. This is the Christmas episode. I have so much to say. I have 12 typed pages today. It looks like you're holding like a mini phone book. I feel like I'm holding a one act play or something. It's very large. And when I came in today, I will share that I refuse to speak to anyone because I said I was saving it for the mic. And I'm saving it for the mic.
圣诞派对。我不信。不，开玩笑的。我们确实这么叫，我们叫它圣诞特辑。我们叫它圣诞特辑，尽管后来还有很多集。这就是圣诞特辑。我有太多话要说了。我今天准备了12页打印出来的笔记。看起来你手里拿的是一本迷你电话簿。我觉得我手里拿的是一出独幕剧什么的。非常厚。我今天进来的时候，我要分享的是，我拒绝和任何人说话，因为我说过我要把话留到麦克风前。我要把话留到麦克风前。
She did. I tried to make a small talk with her and she's like, I'm saving it for the mic. I was like, okay, lady, you do you. I was just, I just going to tell you, I liked your hair. I, you got little pigtails today and they're real cute. I have plaits. What are plaits? That's what they say in the UK. They're like, oh, look at your plaits. Oh, yeah. They also call bangs fringe.
她确实这么做了。我试图和她闲聊，而她说：“我要把话留到麦克风前。”我当时想，好吧，女士，你随意。我只是，我只是想告诉你，我喜欢你的头发。你今天扎了小辫子，真的很可爱。我扎的是辫子（plaits）。什么是plaits？那是英国人的说法。他们会说：“哦，看看你的辫子。”哦，是的。他们还把刘海（bangs）叫作fringe。
I know. I like it. Yeah. I don't know if you notice my side of the table. Totally filled with note cards by my side of the table. You guys, I've made a buffet of note cards. Like I actually have to be aware. Like Sam is saying to stay in front of the microphone because I have so many cards. I keeps, I'm going to have to slide back and forth.
我知道。我喜欢。对。我不知道你有没有注意到我桌子的这一边。我的桌子这一边完全摆满了索引卡。伙们，我做了一场索引卡的自助餐。实际上我必须注意。比如山姆在提醒要待在麦克风前面，因为我有太多的卡片了。我一直在，我得来回滑动。
Yeah. Down my buffet of cards. You love a buffet. I love a buffet. Even if it's note card. Give me that biggest buffet. All right. Christmas party written by Mike shore and directed by Charles McDougal. Here's a synopsis.
是的。顺着我的卡片自助餐。你喜欢自助餐。我喜欢自助餐。哪怕它是索引卡做的。给我来最丰盛的自助餐吧。好了。圣诞派对由迈克·肖尔编剧，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔导演。以下是剧情简介。
Christmas at Dunder Mifflin. Today is the day of the office holiday party. The group originally plans to have a secret Santa gift exchange, but when Michael doesn't like his gift, he turns it into a Yankee swap. This causes a multitude of confusion and hurt feelings. And Michael's solution is then to go out and buy booze, which is against company rules and to try to get the party back on track. 15 bottles of vodka.
邓德米夫林的圣诞节。今天是办公室假日派对的日子。大家原本计划进行神秘圣诞老人礼物交换，但当迈克尔不喜欢他的礼物时，他把它变成了一场白象礼品交换。这导致了极大的混乱和伤感情。而迈克尔的解决方案是出去买酒，这违反了公司规定，并试图让派对重回正轨。15瓶伏特加。
That'll do it. So much. Last fact, number one, as I've already said, it's our very first Christmas episode, but we filmed it nowhere near Christmas. No, you never do because you have to stay ahead. So you're always, it's like Christmas in July kind of thing. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah McGreen. Did us cast members ever have Christmas parties or do a Yankee swap?
这招管用。太多了。幕后花絮一，正如我刚才所说，这是我们的第一集圣诞特辑，但我们拍摄的时间离圣诞节十万八千里。不，你们永远不会在圣诞拍，因为你们必须赶进度。所以总是这样，有点像七月的圣诞节那种感觉。好吧，我们有一个来自萨拉·麦格林的粉丝提问。我们演员们以前办过圣诞派对或玩过白象礼品交换吗？
And if so, what was the best funniest gift someone brought? A lot of people also asked if we exchanged gifts as a cast, not at the holidays. We would do what's called a wrap gift, which happens at the end of the season. And we would usually finish filming our seasons in like, what, April? And then the cast would get together and we'd pull our money and we would buy the crew. Every member of the crew would get a gift from the cast. And then sometimes cast members would give each other wrap gifts.
如果是的话，别人带来最好、最搞笑的礼物是什么？很多人还问我们演员之间是否交换礼物，不是在节假日。我们会做一种叫杀青礼（wrap gift）的事情，发生在拍摄季结束时。我们通常会在大约几月拍完一季，比如四月？然后演员们会聚在一起凑钱，给剧组买礼物。剧组的每位成员都会收到来自演员的礼物。有时演员们也会互赠杀青礼。
Little individual gifts. Yeah. I did host a Yankee swap Christmas party and I did it every year for a few years. And I actually want to bring it back. I took a few years off because just, you know, life kids and, you know, stuff like that. But I hosted a Yankee swap party every year. Oh, yes, you did. And it was a big party and everyone would come and it got so rowdy.
小型的个人礼物。对。我确实举办过白象礼品交换圣诞派对，而且连续好几年每年都办。我其实想把它重新办起来。我停办了几年，因为你知道的，生活、孩子，还有诸如此类的事情。但我每年都举办白象礼品交换派对。哦，没错，你办过。而且是个盛大的派对，每个人都会来，现场气氛变得超级热闹。
Yeah. My favorite person to have at a Yankee swap party is Oscar Nunez. I was going to say Oscar. Oscar. He makes up chance. Like, I remember one of the gifts was like a really lusciously thick, fake ponytail that you ended up bringing. I took that home. Yeah.
是的。我在白象派对上最喜欢的人是奥斯卡·努涅斯。我正要说奥斯卡。奥斯卡。他会编口号。比如，我记得其中一件礼物是一条非常丰满浓密的假马尾辫，最后是你带来的。我把它带回家了。对。
I took home the fake ponytail. Like started chance like pony tail. I mean, they're not really creative chance, but you'd be surprised how much they catch on. I remember one year Lee brought a small hand axe. That thing was super popular. The hot trade. Yes. I want to put it out there.
我把假马尾辫带回家了。就像开始喊口号“马尾辫”。我的意思是，这些口号其实不太有创意，但你会惊讶于它们有多容易流行起来。我记得有一年李带了一把小型手斧。那东西超级受欢迎。抢手货。是的。我想在此提出来。
Guys, if you're going to a Yankee swap, consider bringing a small axe. Didn't the next year Lee brought a brand new water hose? A garden hose. A garden hose. That was also a hot item. Really popular. Just like practical household items that maybe you need, but you haven't been buying yourself. Well, the next Yankee swap party I have, I'm actually going to include the kids because those were adult only.
伙计们，如果你要去参加白象礼品交换，考虑带一把小斧头。难道不是第二年李带了一条崭新的水管吗？一根花园水管。一根花园水管。这也是一件热门商品。非常受欢迎。就像实用的家居用品，也许你用得着，但你一直没给自己买。好吧，我办的下一个白象派对，我打算把孩子们也加进去，因为以前那些只限成人。
Oh, yeah. And I want to do a family Yankee swap. Okay. Like and invite. The kids are such at the age where they're really getting into it. Oh, yeah. We went to one last year. But I want you to know, Jennifer, all the people that used to come.
哦，是的。我想办一个家庭白象派对。好吧。就像发邀请一样。孩子们正处于真正融入其中的年龄。哦，是的。我们去年去过一个。但我想让你知道，珍娜，以前所有来的人。
So at the end of the night, there would be these crap gifts that people would not want. And a friend of mine would unbeknownst to me hide them around my house. I remember this. And I would find them months later because he really hid them. Yeah. Like up, like sort of on a top shelf by like the spare batteries would be like a weird porcelain clown. Yeah. You know, and Zach Woods brought this gift and he said, Angela, I am the failure of Yankee
所以在派对结束时，总会有一些大家不想要的烂礼物。我的一位朋友会在我不知情的情况下把它们藏在我家的各处。我记得这个。几个月后我还会找到它们，因为他是真的把它们藏起来了。是的。比如藏在某个高架子上，备用电池旁边，会有一个奇怪的瓷小丑。是的。你知道的，扎克·伍兹带了这份礼物，他说：“安吉拉，我是白象派对的失败者，”
swap because he brought a Egyptian. The King, the King Tut thing. It was a King Tut miniature sarcophagus. Yeah. That opened up and you could put things inside it. I fought for that. I thought it was really great. I loved that.
因为他带了一个埃及的。图坦卡蒙，图坦卡蒙的东西。那是一个图坦卡蒙的微型石棺。是的。可以打开，你还能把东西放进去。我为了那个据理力争。我觉得它真的很棒。我很喜欢。
Well, it got traded a bunch and he was like, I don't think anyone likes it. I was like, Zach, you're wrong. I know I'm talking a lot about my Yankee swap party guys, but I was really inspired. Well, this is a side note about Zach Woods. You guys, he played Gabe in later seasons and he became a good friend of ours. When my son was born, he did the same thing. He gave me a gift and he said, I'm so sorry. I'm not good at buying gifts for children.
好吧，它被转手了好几次，他说：“我觉得没人喜欢它。”我当时就说：“扎克，你错了。”我知道我一直在滔滔不绝地讲我的白象派对，伙计们，但我真的很受启发。好吧，这是关于扎克·伍兹的一个趣事。伙计们，他在后来的几季中饰演加布，成了我们的好朋友。我儿子出生时，他也做了同样的事。他送了我一份礼物，并说：“真的很抱歉。我不太擅长给小孩子买礼物。
I don't have kids yet. I don't know. And it was this amazing astronaut costume that we still have today and used for dress up. I think he's better at buying gifts than he is. I think you are, Zach. Just FYI. All right. Fast fact number two.
我还没孩子呢。我不知道。”那是这套神奇的宇航员服装，我们至今还留着，用来角色扮演。我觉得他在买礼物方面比他自己认为的要好。我觉得你很会挑，扎克。仅供参考。好吧，幕后花絮二。
This episode was directed by Charles McDougal. Oh guys, do we have stories about Charles McDougal? I mean. First of all, he was British. Yes. I'm bringing out the accent guys. I did my spin bike and now I'm speaking like a Brit. He had directed before us the HBO series, Rome, which if anyone saw it is about the
这一集由查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。哦，伙计们，我们有关于查尔斯·麦克杜格尔的故事吗？我的意思是。首先，他是英国人。是的。我要飙英国口音了，伙计们。我刚骑完动感单车，现在我说话就像个英国人了。他在此之前执导过HBO剧集《罗马》，如果有人看过的话，讲的是
Roman Empire and the killing of Julius Caesar. It is epic. It's also brutal. It's brutal. They shot in Malta. There was chariots and horses and people getting impaled. Yes. And so he went from that to our quiet little Dunder Mifflin office.
古罗马帝国和凯撒大帝之死。这太史诗了。同时也很残酷。真的很残酷。他们在马耳他拍摄。里面有战车、马匹，还有人被刺穿。是的。因此，他从那种大场面来到了我们安静的小邓德米夫林办公室。
A little Christmas party. A little Christmas party. And you guys, the directors that had directed us prior to him were Ken Qopis, who might be the quietest human on the planet. Correct. He says, you know, when he wants to start a scene, he just says, uh, go ahead. And when he gives a note, he'll say, Jenna, um, you know what? No, just go ahead.
一个小型的圣诞派对。一个小型的圣诞派对。大家知道吗，在他之前执导过我们的导演是肯·库皮斯，他可能是地球上最安静的人。没错。他说，你知道的，当他想开始一个场景时，他只会说，呃，开始吧。当他给出意见时，他会说，珍娜，嗯，你知道吗？不，直接开始吧。
Yeah. That's Ken Qopis. Yeah. You all heard Paul Feig. Paul Feig is like, Hey gang, how's it going? Hey, we're going to have fun today. Okay. Action.
对。那是肯·库皮斯。是的。你们都听过保罗·费格。保罗·费格就像是，嘿，伙计们，最近怎么样？嘿，我们今天要玩得开心。好的。动作。
Yeah. Charles McDougal rolls in. We're all sitting at our desks quietly about to start the first scene. And he goes, wait, brace yourself, brace yourself, brace yourself. Actors. Action. Yes. We, I thought Phyllis peed herself a little.
是的。查尔斯·麦克道格尔大摇大摆地走进来。我们都静静地坐在办公桌前，准备开始第一场戏。然后他说，等等，稳住，稳住，稳住。演员们。动作。是的。我们，我觉得菲莉丝吓得有点尿裤子了。
I tinkled. I tinkled. I was terrified. I jumped straight up. He was like, Oh my gosh. What's happening? What's happening? Is Tom Cruise busting through the ceiling any minute?
我漏尿了。我漏尿了。我吓坏了。我猛地跳了起来。他就像是，哦，天哪。怎么回事？怎么回事？汤姆·克鲁斯会不会随时从天花板冲下来？
I'm telling you that first day, the first moment of every scene, we all looked like deer in headlights. We would flinch. We would flinch. And then we would go into scene. But then you guys, we just grew to love this guy. Oh. He would say things like we'd be working on a scene and he'd be like, all right, you
我告诉你，第一天，每个场景的第一个瞬间，我们看起来都像是在强光前的鹿。我们会退缩。我们会退缩。然后我们才会进入场景。但是后来，伙计们，我们渐渐开始爱上这家伙了。哦。他会说这样的话，比如我们正在拍一场戏，然后他会说，好了，你们
know, let's go again. Actors nearly there. And then I, he one time, he one time said, he said, all right, everyone, that was good for cameras. Actors better this time. Yeah. Okay. And then as we try to be better this time, as we got into the episode more and the party
知道的，再来一次。演员们表现得快到位了。然后我，他有一次，他有一次说，他说，好了，大家，镜头效果不错。演员们这次要表现得更好。Yeah. 好的。然后，当我们试图这一次表现得更好时，随着我们对剧集的深入以及派对
started, he would walk up to me and be like, Angela, remember, you're really pissed. You're really pissed now. And he sort of, and I'm going to get into it. It's on, it's on like four or five note cards, but he sort of highlighted the level of, I called it Angela's pissed offness. Yeah. And it had like, it was like building to a crescendo. And so towards the end, he would just yell before a big take in the party.
的开始，他会走到我面前说，安吉拉，记住，你真的很生气。你现在真的很生气。他有点，而且我会进入状态。它写在大概四五张便条卡上，但他某种程度上强调了那种程度，我称之为安吉拉的愤怒值。是的。这就像是逐渐走向高潮。所以在快结束时，在派对上的一个大特写镜头前，他会直接大喊。
He'd be like, all right, everyone happy, Angela pissed and action. Yes. It was amazing. It was amazing. I just think it's so interesting that he went from filming all these chariots to filming people in a circle. Yeah. Sitting in a circle.
他会说，好了，大家都高兴，安吉拉生气，然后动作。是的。这太棒了。这太棒了。我只是觉得很有趣，他从拍摄所有这些战车转变为拍摄人们围成一圈。是的。围坐成一圈。
What was that like for him? On desk chairs. Yes. Okay. Fast fact number three, Bob Vance, Vance refrigeration. We meet Phyllis's boyfriend. Yes. Her new boyfriend.
对他来说那是怎样的体验？坐在办公椅上。是的。好的，冷知识第三条，鲍勃·凡斯，凡斯制冷公司。我们见到了菲莉丝的男友。是的。她的新男友。
He works across the hall. He's played by Bobby Ray Schaefer. He went on to do 24 episodes of the office, including our finale. So here's a little tidbit. I'm sure our writer said that the way that Bob Vance always introduces himself as Bob Vance, Vance refrigeration, is based on a friend of his, actor Hayes MacArthur, who he says for years would introduce himself as Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois. Hayes MacArthur, Chicago, Illinois.
他在大厅对面工作。扮演他的是鲍比·雷·谢弗。他后来演了24集的《办公室》，包括我们的结局。所以这里有个小花絮。我敢肯定我们的编剧说过，鲍勃·凡斯总是自我介绍说我是鲍勃·凡斯，凡斯制冷公司，是基于他的一个朋友，演员海斯·麦克阿瑟，他说他多年来一直自我介绍说，海斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。海斯·麦克阿瑟，伊利诺伊州芝加哥。
You guys, you might know Hayes. He would later go on to star with Rashida Jones on Angie Tribeca, which was created by Steve and Nancy Carell. Small world. But I feel comfortable sharing that story about Hayes because I know him as well. And Mike said it on the DVD commentary. So he shared that with us on set. But since he put it out there, I was like, well, Mike, you already said it.
大家，你们可能认识海斯。他后来与拉什达·琼斯一起主演了由史蒂夫和南希·卡瑞尔创作的《爆笑女警》。世界真小。但我很乐意分享关于海斯的这个故事，因为我也认识他。而且迈克在DVD评论中说过。所以他在片场跟我们分享了这一点。但既然他都公开了，我就想，好吧，迈克，你已经说过了。
So I'm going to share it here. Yeah. Well, you know what? I think that some people do that. I mean, I know in my hometown, you know, I'm from a very small town in Texas. Uh-huh. And there are people in my town that we, no one ever says just their first name. I don't know why, but my mom's really good friend.
所以我在这里分享一下。好吧，你知道吗？我觉得有些人就是这样。我的意思是，我知道在我的家乡，你知道的，我来自德克萨斯州的一个小镇。嗯。我的镇上有些人，我们，从来没有人只叫他们的名字。我不知道为什么，但我妈妈特别好的朋友。
Her first name is Sue and her last name is Dean. But every one of the town calls her Sue Dean. Oh, yeah. Hi, Sue Dean. How are you, Sue Dean? It'd be like, Jenna Fisher. How are you, Jenna Fisher? I'm good, Jenna Fisher.
她名叫苏，姓迪恩。但镇上的每个人都叫她苏·迪恩。哦，是的。嗨，苏·迪恩。你好吗，苏·迪恩？就像是，珍娜·费舍尔。你好吗，珍娜·费舍尔？我很好，珍娜·费舍尔。
I mean, it's so, there are some people whose names just, you just do that. Yeah. Well, we had some fans right in and ask, why does he always say Bob Vance? Vance refrigeration. It was inspired by one of Mike's friends. I love it. Many people, before we go to break, many people wrote in to tell us that Mindy's hair is down. I've, I've maybe not received so many.
我的意思是，太，有些人名字就是这样，你自然而然就会那样做。是的。好吧，有一些粉丝写信来问，为什么他总是说鲍勃·凡斯？凡斯制冷公司。这是受到迈克的一个朋友的启发。我喜欢这个。在进入休息之前，很多人，很多人写信告诉我们明迪的头发是放下来的。我，我可能没收到过这么多。
In this episode? No, it's in this episode. No. It's down. No, it's partially up. It's partially up. Oh, well, Jennifer Danette said that Mindy's hair is down. Jennifer Danette, I'm going to send you a screen grab.
在这集里？没有，是在这集里。没有。是放下来的。没有，是半扎起来的。是半扎起来的。哦，好吧，詹妮弗·达内特说明迪的头发是放下来的。詹妮弗·达内特，我要给你发一张截图。
I mean, maybe she means down because it's not in the French twist. It's not in the French twist, but she has had a few. It is. It's half up, half down. She's had a few half up, half downs, but I would say there's more down than up. Jennifer, there's more down than up. That's what she said. Well, I hope she doesn't say that.
我的意思是，也许她说放下来是因为它没有盘成法式发髻。它没有盘成法式发髻，但她确实有过几次。是的。是半扎半放的。她有过几次半扎半放的造型，但我要说放下来的比扎起来的多。詹妮弗，放下来的比扎起来的多。她是这么说的。好吧，我希望她没这么说。
Well, we would hope there's more up than down. All right, let's go to break. All right, so let's dive in here. We've got the cold open in the very first few seconds. Pam is stuffing the Christmas envelopes, the Christmas photo. Yeah. Right? She's doing the Christmas card mask mailing.
好吧，我们希望扎起来的比放下来的多。好了，我们去休息一下。好的，那我们这就深入探讨。我们在最初的几秒钟里有冷场开场。帕姆正在装圣诞信封，圣诞照片。是的。对吧？她在群发圣诞贺卡。
The Christmas card. I did this at 1-800-Denest. Oh, you did the 1-800-Denest company Christmas card mailing? I did. I volunteered and you got to hop off the phone so you didn't have to talk to people about, like, their rotten teeth. Yeah. And I would go in the mail room and they'd be playing Christmas music and I'd have a
圣诞贺卡。我在1-800-Denest做过这个。哦，你做过1-800-Denest公司的圣诞贺卡群发？我做过。我自愿去的，这样你就可以不用接电话，不用和别人讨论诸如他们腐烂的牙齿之类的问题。是的。然后我会去收发室，他们会放着圣诞音乐，我有一
cup of tea and I would just stuff envelopes all day and I was so happy. Oh, yeah. I did many, many mass mailings as an administrative assistant. I'd have to bind things, copy on both sides, collate, bind and mail. I'm very happy doing those things. Okay, but the photo was our cast photo that we took, our Christmas photo. It was not our Christmas photo. What?
杯茶，然后我整天都在装信封，我太高兴了。哦，是的。作为行政助理，我做过很多很多次群发邮件。我得装订文件，双面复印，整理，装订然后寄出。做这些事情我非常高兴。好吧，但那张照片是我们拍的演员合影，我们的圣诞照片。那不是我们的圣诞照片。什么？
Oh, yeah. It was. I, listen, I maybe got a little too obsessed with it, but I thought I recognized it. It was me too. It's our season one publicity photo from the pilot. You're right! Because I'm sitting in the front. Oh, my gosh.
哦，是的。是的。我，听着，我可能对此有点太着迷了，但我以为我认出来了。我也是。那是我们在试播集的第一季宣传照。你说得对！因为我坐在最前面。哦，天哪。
And we're not wearing any Christmas stuff. Oh, Jenna. Good catch. I, I totally just thought it was our Christmas picture. Well, we had a fan question from Pizuki. Did anyone keep a copy of the holiday card Pam is stuffing into the envelopes at the beginning? Well, I don't have a copy of the card, but I have a copy of that picture hanging in
而且我们没有穿任何圣诞节的东西。哦，珍娜。好眼力。我，我完全以为那是我们的圣诞照片。好吧，我们有一个来自皮祖基的粉丝问题。有没有人保留了一份帕姆在开头塞进信封里的节日贺卡的副本？嗯，我没有贺卡的副本，但我有一张那张照片的副本挂在
my office and I examined it against the card that Pam is putting into the envelopes. Well, remember in the pilot. Who's my detective? Henriette. Thank you so much, CSI office ladies. Henriette is in that photo. Henriette is in the photo on my wall because she was in the pilot. They photoshopped Kate's head onto Henriette's body for the picture I'm stuffing into the
我的办公室里，我拿它跟帕姆塞进信封里的卡片做了对比。好吧，还记得在试播集里。我的侦探是谁？亨丽埃特。非常感谢，办公室女士CSI侦探。亨丽埃特就在那张照片里。亨丽埃特在我墙上的照片里，因为她出演了试播集。为了我在这集里塞进信封的照片，他们把凯特的头P到了亨丽埃特的身体上。
envelope in this episode. I really want that card. Dang it. Yeah, because I can see it's Henriette's hand on her hip in the sweater that's hanging in my office, but Kate's face. Way to go, Jenna. So far we've covered one second of the episode that happens in the first one to three seconds. The next thing that happens is that Michael and Dwight enter with the tree and it's really
我真的很想要那张卡片。该死。对，因为我能看到挂在我办公室里的毛衣上那是亨丽埃特叉着腰的手，但脸却是凯特的。干得好，珍娜。到目前为止，我们只讲了发生在第一到三秒钟之间的一秒钟剧情。接下来发生的是迈克尔和德怀特带着一棵树进来，这树真的
way too big. It's way too big. It goes through the ceiling. I feel like this is a little nod to Christmas vacation. Yes. You know, with Chevy Chase and that enormous tree. Yes. Well, do you remember when we were on set about three or four times when they pushed it up,
太大了。太大了。它直接穿过了天花板。我觉得这有点是在向《疯狂圣诞假期》致敬。是的。你知道的，就是切维·切斯和那棵巨大的树。是的。好吧，你还记得我们在片场的时候，有三四次他们把它往上推时，
the ceiling towel actually fell down and would fall on Steve's head. And then they'd have to brush him off with a little brush and fix his hair. There was little pieces of white sort of like particle looking stuff all over the ground because the ceiling kept busting apart. Yeah. I loved that Kevin cuts the top of the Christmas tree with a paper trimmer. Yeah. I just thought that was such a nice touch.
天花板瓷砖真的掉了下来，砸到了史蒂夫的头上。然后他们不得不拿一把小刷子把他身上的东西刷掉，帮他弄好头发。地上全是一小块一小块白色的像颗粒一样的东西，因为天花板一直在崩塌。是的。我喜欢凯文用切纸机切掉圣诞树顶。是的。我只是觉得这真是一个绝妙的细节。
Well, it makes sense. It's what we'd have. It's what we would have. Yeah. Okay. I did kind of an Angela thing. What's that? Did you drink Rose during the day?
好吧，这说得通。这是我们会做的事。这是我们会做的事。是的。好吧，我做了一件很安吉拉的事。什么事？你在白天喝了桃红葡萄酒吗？
I did not. But I did, I wrote down everybody's Christmas outfits. I love this. So did I. You did? Okay. Let's do it. Let's do it.
我没有。但我确实，我写下了每个人的圣诞服装。我喜欢这个。我也是。你也是吗？好的。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。
Okay. All right. I noticed that Michael has a Christmas tie. Yes, he does. It has a Santa on it and some snowman go. Christmas tie, Kevin. Yes. Snowman, wintry scene.
好的。好的。我注意到迈克尔系着一条圣诞领带。是的，他确实系了。上面有一个圣诞老人和一些雪人。圣诞领带，凯文。是的。雪人，冬日景色。
All right. You and I both only have a Christmas pin and Christmas earrings. You have Christmas ornament earrings. I have Christmas stocking earrings. We both have a version of a Santa Claus pin. Interesting. We're dressed kind of similar. Very similarly.
好吧。你和我身上都只有一枚圣诞胸针和圣诞耳环。你戴的是圣诞饰品耳环。我戴的是圣诞袜耳环。我们俩都戴着某种版本的圣诞老人胸针。有趣。我们穿得挺像的。非常相似。
What's that about? I don't know. But Phyllis has a full Christmas blouse and vest. I love her Christmas vest. My sister's a school teacher and she does that. Like at Christmas time, she wears all these Christmas sweaters and vests. You know I love this stuff. I've got all of it.
这是怎么回事？我不知道。但菲莉丝穿着一套完整的圣诞衬衫和马甲。我喜欢她的圣诞马甲。我妹妹是个学校老师，她就会那样穿。就像在圣诞节期间，她会穿所有这些圣诞毛衣和马甲。你知道我喜欢这些东西。我全都有。
My mom back in St. Louis, Missouri, every year she goes to the local art fairs and craft fairs and she sends me Christmas hoodies, Christmas vests, Christmas pajamas, Christmas everything. I mean those earrings could have been yours because you've come to my house at Christmas and you always have on Christmas jewelry. I'll tell you right now I would never show up at a Christmas party and only Christmas earrings and Christmas pin. I know. I mean that is, I know.
我妈妈在密苏里州圣路易斯，她每年都会去当地的艺术集市和手工艺集市，然后她会寄给我圣诞连帽衫、圣诞马甲、圣诞睡衣，圣诞应有尽有。我的意思是那些耳环本来可以是你的，因为你圣诞节来过我家，你总是戴着圣诞首饰。我现在就告诉你，我绝不会只戴着圣诞耳环和圣诞胸针就去参加圣诞派对。我知道。我的意思是，那是，我知道。
I go all out. You go all out. Oh, Oscar has a Christmas tie. Oscar has a Christmas tie. Stanley has a red tie. So I guess that's his attempt. Very Stanley. That's as far as he would go.
我全力以赴。你全力以赴。哦，奥斯卡系着一条圣诞领带。奥斯卡系着一条圣诞领带。斯坦利系着一条红领带。所以我想那是他的尝试。非常斯坦利。这就是他能做到的极限了。
I'm actually surprised he went that far. No. For Stanley. I know. Also Meredith has a crazy Christmas sweater. Yeah. See if it were me, I would be Meredith or Phyllis showing up to your party. Full outfit.
我其实很惊讶他能做到这一步。不。对斯坦利来说。我知道。还有梅雷迪思有一件疯狂的圣诞毛衣。是的。如果是我的话，我就会像梅雷迪思或菲莉丝那样去你的派对。全套装备。
I know. I've seen how you come to my party. I love it. All right. So in this scene that's coming up, Jim reveals that he got Pam in Secret Santa. He does. Can I listen, Jim fans, you're probably not going to like me for saying this, but at two minutes, two seconds in his talking head, he says he wants, you know, he got Pam for
我知道。我见过你是怎么来我的派对的。我很喜欢。好的。那么在接下来这个场景中，吉姆透露他在秘密圣诞老人活动中抽到了帕姆。他确实抽到了。我可以，听着，吉姆的粉丝们，你们可能不会喜欢我这么说，但在两分钟两秒时他的访谈中，他说他希望，你知道的，他抽到了帕姆
Secret Santa and he said, because Pam wants a teapot so she can make tea at her desk. Yeah. And I wrote WTF. Who makes tea at their desk? She would go in the kitchen. What is she going to do? Go to the kitchen, put the hot water in the teapot, carry it back to her desk, pour herself a cup of tea at her desk.
秘密圣诞老人，他说，因为帕姆想要一个茶壶，这样她就可以在办公桌上泡茶了。是的。我写下了WTF。谁在办公桌上泡茶？她会去厨房的。她要做什么？去厨房，把热水倒进茶壶里，把它拿回办公桌，在办公桌上给自己倒一杯茶。
Exactly. She's going to carry that teapot from the kitchen. What part of this is confusing you? I think is ridiculous. Okay. Here's her other option. Okay. Yeah.
没错。她要端着那个茶壶从厨房走过来。这有什么好让你困惑的？我觉得这太荒谬了。好吧。这是她的另一个选择。好吧。是的。
She goes into the kitchen. Yeah. Oh, I see the breakdown. I see how your brain is tracking it and why it doesn't make sense. And also because I know you and you just put the teabag right into the cup, which is a totally acceptable way to make it. I know some people let it, let it steep. Steep.
她去厨房。哦，我看出问题所在了。我看出你的大脑是怎么理清这个逻辑的了，以及为什么它说不通。而且因为我了解你，你直接把茶包放进杯子里，这完全是一种可以接受的泡茶方式。我知道有些人会让它，让它浸泡。浸泡。
Steep. With a tea. Let it steep on in there. You leave it in your pot. That's right. I said that the scene could be called something else. What could it be called? Instead of what's inside the teapot, it could be called Jim's Got It Bad.
浸泡。用茶。让它在那里面浸泡。你把它留在壶里。没错。我说过这个场景可以叫别的名字。可以叫什么名字？与其叫茶壶里有什么，不如叫吉姆陷得很深。
Oh. Because he saved two sauce packets from a few years ago. Yeah. That's someone who has got it really bad. Okay. Yeah. I think that could have been written a little differently where Jim could have said a couple of years ago Pam did this thing with the hot sauce and therefore I am putting a packet
哦。因为他把几年前的两包酱料包留了下来。是的。那是爱得很深的人才会做的事。好吧。是的。我觉得这里可以写得稍微不同一点，吉姆可以说几年前帕姆用辣酱做过某件事，因此我把一包
of hot sauce in there. The fact that he saved the two packets of hot sauce for years, for years. Yeah. He loves you. He loves you. Okay. Definitely does. All right.
辣酱放在了里面。事实上，他把这两包辣酱留了好几年，留了好几年。是的。他爱你。他爱你。好吧。绝对是这样。好的。
Well, I do have a lot to say about the teapot. So first of all, Phil Shea offered me a variety of teapots before we started shooting in many colors and I picked the teal. I love it. Yeah. I don't know. Little pop of color. The writers also said that picking what this gift would be, the fact that it would be a
好吧，我对这个茶壶确实有很多话要说。首先，在我们开始拍摄之前，菲尔·谢伊给我提供了各种颜色、各种各样的茶壶，我挑了蓝绿色的。我喜欢它。是的。不知道。一点亮色。编剧们还说，挑选这个礼物会是什么，它是一个
teapot provided a major challenge because they needed a gift that could hide other gifts that was really personal and that would be very stressful when Dwight takes it away from Pam. It could only cost $20 and it had to be something that Dwight really wanted. And they said it was not easy. They spent a very long time because they knew plot-wise what had to happen, that Jim gives Pam a gift filled with secret treasures that Dwight also wants to have that costs under $20.
茶壶，这带来了巨大的挑战，因为他们需要一个能够藏匿其他礼物的礼物，这个礼物必须非常私人，而且当德怀特把它从帕姆手里拿走时会让人感到非常紧张。它只能价值20美元以内，而且必须是德怀特真正想要的东西。他们说这可不容易。他们花了很长时间，因为他们知道剧情上必须发生什么，也就是吉姆送给帕姆一件装满秘密宝藏的礼物，而德怀特也想要得到它，并且价格在20美元以下。
It took them a very long time to come up with teapot. For that reason alone, okay, fine. Pam can make her tea at the counter because when Dwight puts it in his nose, I know that's later, but it's so perfect. It is. It's so perfect. They nailed it, right? They nailed it.
他们花了很长很长时间才想出茶壶这个点子。仅凭这一点，好吧，行。帕姆可以在柜台上泡茶，因为当德怀特把它塞进鼻子时，我知道那是后来的事了，但它太完美了。是的。太完美了。他们拿捏住了，对吧？他们拿捏住了。
And now this teapot is famous. I mean, all the time people are using this teapot idea to propose to their loved ones. I see it all the time and my Instagram people are tagging me. It's always charming to me. It's always so sweet. It is very thoughtful. So we mentioned the things that he's putting into the teapot. Here's a fan question.
现在这个茶壶出名了。我是说，人们一直都在用这个茶壶的点子向他们的挚爱求婚。我经常看到，我的Instagram上的人都在圈我。这对我来说总是很有魅力。总是那么甜蜜。这确实非常贴心。所以我们提到了他塞进茶壶里的东西。这里有一个粉丝问题。
Taylor Rilling said, what is the significance of the pencil that Jim puts in the teapot? Yeah, he said that the story is too long. So we have a deleted scene. And I remember shooting it. What Pam says when she picks up the pencil is she says, oh my gosh, this is the pencil I threw at you during mini-golf. What? When did Jim and Pam go play mini-golf?
泰勒·里林问，吉姆放进茶壶里的铅笔有什么意义？是的，他说这个故事太长了。所以我们有一个被删掉的场景。我记得拍过这个。帕姆拿起铅笔时说的话是，哦，天哪，这是我在迷你高尔夫时扔向你的那支铅笔！什么？吉姆和帕姆什么时候去打过迷你高尔夫？
Maybe the whole office went and played mini-golf. That seems like something Michael Scott would be like, we're going to play mini-golf and we're going to raise money for my neighbors, like whatever. That's all I can think of is that there was some office outing where they went and played mini-golf and I guess Pam got all feisty and threw a pencil at him and he saved it. So that's where the pencil is. And then of course he puts a card in the box and he says, because Christmas time is the time to tell people how you feel.
也许整个办公室都去打过迷你高尔夫了。这听起来像是迈克尔·斯科特会做的事，他会说，我们要去打迷你高尔夫，我们要为我的邻居筹款，诸如此类的。我能想到的就是有一次办公室集体出游去打了迷你高尔夫，我猜帕姆当时好胜心强，向他扔了一支铅笔，而他把它留作纪念了。所以这就是那支铅笔的由来。然后当然他在盒子里放了一张卡片，他说，因为圣诞节是向人们表达你真实感受的时候。
Oh yeah, that's so loaded. I have PPC next. Let's hit some PPC, the party planning committee. You know, Mike Scherr also wrote the PPC and the Alliance. I think he likes the PPC. He definitely likes the PPC and their weird sort of power struggle. He loves it. Well, in this scene, we find out that Ryan has been drafted into the PPC.
哦，是的，这话信息量太大了。接下来我记了PPC。让我们聊聊PPC，也就是派对策划委员会。你知道，迈克·舍尔还写了PPC和同盟。我觉得他很喜欢PPC。他绝对喜欢PPC以及他们那种奇怪的权力斗争。他很喜欢。好吧，在这个场景中，我们发现瑞安被征召加入了PPC。
I can't believe that. I remember that. I can't believe that Angela Martin would recruit him, except that maybe she needed help like someone setting up things and moving things and. Well, the Christmas party is a big one. It's a big one. Yeah. But also I noticed that Meredith is in there.
我简直不敢相信。我记得那个。我简直不敢相信安吉拉·马丁会招募他，除非她可能需要人帮忙搭建和搬运东西。好吧，圣诞派对是个大派对。这是个大派对。是的。不过我也注意到梅雷迪思也在里面。
Yeah. No, it's all hands on deck. She probably has a bigger crew than just her core crew. Well, that's when Michael enters in his Santa beard. He throws down some cash because he wants a bigger, better party and he reveals he has a digital camera and he will be taking photos. Yeah. And he's going to put them in the newsletter.
是的。不，这是全员出动。她手下的人可能不仅仅是核心成员。好吧，就在这时，迈克尔戴着圣诞老人胡子登场了。他甩出一些现金，因为他想要一个更大、更好的派对，并且他透露他有一台数码相机，他会拍照。是的。而且他会把照片放进时事通讯里。
Most embarrassing one wins. Yes. I want you guys to know when Steve came behind Phyllis and I and he was like, I want people making out and he shoved her heads together and was like, that was an impromptu. That was impromptu. Yeah. Phyllis and I didn't know that was coming. He just did it in the moment.
最尴尬的获胜。是的。我想让你们知道，当史蒂夫来到菲莉丝和我身后，他就像是，我想要人们卿卿我我，然后他把我们的头推到一起，说，这是即兴发挥。那是即兴发挥。是的。菲莉丝和我事先并不知道会这样。他当时就那么做了。
I was really proud that neither of us started laughing. I'm so proud of myself because there were a few times in that scene I almost broke and I was really fighting it. Oh, it's also in the scene Angela that it's revealed that Phyllis was in charge of getting the lights for the Christmas tree. And she said she got the little ones. Yeah. And you have a reaction to that.
我真的很自豪我们两个都没有笑出来。我为自己感到骄傲，因为那个场景中有好几次我差点笑场，我一直在努力克制。哦，安吉拉，也是在这个场景中，透露出菲莉丝负责为圣诞树买灯。而她说她买的是小串的。是的。你对此有反应。
Well, that's not going to go over well later. That is not going to go over. So I did. Like I said, I listened to the DVD commentary of this and Mike was really good on the commentary at breaking down some of his goals for the episode. And his goal for the episode was that Angela would get more and more and more stressed out every scene that we see her. And I think you can track that like as I was watching it again, I can totally see that.
好吧，这待会儿可不好过。那可真是不好过。所以我确实。就像我说的，我听了这集的DVD评论音轨，迈克在评论中非常出色地剖析了他对这集的一些目标。他这一集的目标是，安吉拉在每一个出场的场景中都会变得越来越焦虑。我觉得你可以追踪到这一点，当我再次观看时，我完全能看出来。
I have five note cards called Angela's Pissed Offness that I'm going to start with time code soon. Before we get into all that, I do have to point out because I was texting with Kim Ferry who did my hair for nine years on the office last night. This is the Angela hair braid. That is my actual hair that she had me bend over and braid. And of course my character would want to wear it to the Christmas party. I feel like this was her special braid for special occasions, special occasions.
我有五张名为“安吉拉的愤怒值”的便条卡，我很快就会结合时间码开始讲。在我们深入讨论所有这些之前，我确实得指出一点，因为我昨晚跟金·费里发了短信，她在《办公室》为我做了九年头发。这就是安吉拉的发辫。那是我真正的头发，她让我弯下腰编出来的。当然，我的角色会想戴着它去参加圣诞派对。我觉得这是她为特殊场合准备的特殊发辫，特殊场合。
And while we're talking PPC guys, I have to say Pam, Pam would probably irk me too on this committee. What? I mean, at four minutes, 25 seconds, Angela is trying to put a tablecloth on this table. Pam is just staring at her doing nothing, not trying to grab for the tablecloth, help her spread it out, anything. And Angela just looks at her and is just like, will you help me? When I saw that scene, I found it so satisfying.
而且在我们谈论PPC的时候，伙计们，我必须说帕姆，帕姆在这个委员会里可能也会惹恼我。什么？我是说，在四分钟25秒时，安吉拉正试图把桌布铺在这个桌子上。帕姆就只是盯着她什么也不做，也没有试着去拿桌布，帮她铺开，什么都没有。然后安吉拉看着她，就像是，你能帮我一下吗？当我看到那个场景时，我感到太满足了。
It's her little bit of defiance against your just crazy controlling, yes, yes, just your everything that's coming at her. And you know, I told you I go back and I read my journals and I had written and I also have these old blogs. And I had written in one of my old blogs that filming the scene where I don't help you put the tablecloth on was one of my favorites of the whole episode is such like passive aggressive defiance. I loved it.
那是她对你那种疯狂控制欲的一点点反抗，是的，是的，对你向她倾泻的一切的反抗。你知道的，我告诉过你我回去翻看我的日记，我写过，而且我还有这些旧博客。我在其中一篇旧博客里写过，拍摄我不帮你铺桌布的那个场景是我整集中最喜欢的场景之一，这是一种非常被动的消极抵抗。我太喜欢了。
I loved it. Well, Jenna, I went and found my MySpace blogs. So they're not online anymore. I don't know why, but I so but I guess before I had printed them out at some point smart. So now I'm going to start going to them for each episode and I did for this one, but I'll save it for a bit because it happens later in the episode. Okay, great. So one question from small actor in a P coat.
我太喜欢了。好吧，珍娜，我去找了我的MySpace博客。所以它们已经不在网上了。我不知道为什么，但我所以，不过我猜我之前在某个时候把它们打印出来了，真聪明。所以现在我打算为每一集都翻出它们来看看，我这集也这么做了，但我先保留一下，因为这发生在后面的剧情中。好的，太棒了。那么，来自穿呢子大衣的小演员的一个问题。
Who kept the camera with all of the pictures that Michael took in BC? Yeah, they were property of NBC and they had them up on their website for a while. But guess what? You can still find them. And Jenna and I were texting last night. We both found them over at office tally.com. Yeah. So you can see all those pictures that he was really taking pictures.
谁保留了迈克尔在BC拍的所有照片的相机？是的，它们是NBC的财产，它们在他们的网站上挂了一段时间。但你猜怎么着？你仍然可以找到它们。而且珍娜和我昨晚发短信了。我们在officetally.com上都找到了它们。是的。所以你可以看到所有那些照片，他真的是在拍照。
Yeah. And they're really like not centered and like people's heads are cut off. It's as if he just went around clicking away, but there's some real gyms in there. I know. Six minutes, 54 seconds. Michael really, really shows what he thinks about Christmas, which is a gift should say I love you this mini dollars worth. Yeah.
是的，而且它们真的没有对准中心，就像人们的头被切掉了一样。就好像他只是四处走动随便乱按快门，但里面确实有一些真正的宝藏。我知道。六分钟54秒。迈克尔真正地、真正地展现了他对圣诞节的看法，那就是一份礼物应该表达我爱你这价值多少钱。是的。
Oh, this is not going to go well. Well speaking of gifts, we have a scene where Toby reveals what he got Angela in Secret Santa and it is the jazz baby poster. Yeah. I have that poster guys. You have it? That was one of my questions from Chris Cordova. He wants to know, did you keep the baby poster?
哦，这下要糟了。说到礼物，我们有一个场景，托比透露了他在秘密圣诞老人中送给安吉拉的礼物，是一张爵士宝贝海报。是的。我有那张海报，伙计们。你真的有？那是克里斯·科尔多瓦的问题之一。他想知道，你留下了那张宝贝海报吗？
Well, there was about 20 of them. They made a bunch. One hung by my desk for years. Yes. Yeah. So we got to see it every day. And I have one. It's rolled up in a little poster thingy.
嗯，大约有20个。他们做了很多。有一个挂在我桌子旁边好几年了。是的。对。所以我们每天都能看到它。我还有一个。它卷在一个小海报筒里。
Now do you know the story behind that picture? Because I traded some text messages with Phil Shea. So Phil Shea had to make that poster. He did not buy that poster. He put out a casting call for babies. And two babies were cast, baby actors. He said it was really hard to find tiny jazz instruments. He said that was really difficult.
现在你知道那张照片背后的故事吗？因为我和菲尔·希尔（Phil Shea）发过短信。所以那张海报是菲尔·希尔制作的。他没有买那张海报。他发布了婴儿演员的选角通告。有两个婴儿被选中，也就是婴儿演员。他说找微型爵士乐器真的很难。他说那非常困难。
In fact, he said, you know, Amazon didn't exist back then. You know, you couldn't just Google baby jazz instrument. And they couldn't be fake looking like they couldn't be like blue and pink. So he did eventually find them at a place called Hollywood Costumes. He was particularly proud of the tiny sunglasses that he found. This poster ends up coming back in conflict resolution. Like you said, it stayed up there, but then it comes back again. It comes back again.
事实上，他说，你知道，那时候亚马逊还不存在。你知道的，你不能在谷歌上直接搜索婴儿爵士乐器。而且它们不能看起来很假，比如不能是蓝色和粉红色的。所以他最终在一家叫做“好莱坞服装”的地方找到了它们。他对找到的那些微型太阳镜感到特别自豪。这张海报最终在剧情冲突解决时又出现了。就像你说的，它一直挂在那儿，但后来又出现了。它又出现了。
I would like to know the two babies that were in the poster. Oh, guys, where are they today? If you are a baby from the baby jazz poster, will you please write to us. At officeladiesatearwolf.com. One thing about that baby jazz poster, I remember Mike Schur telling me that they thought it was really funny that Angela would really enjoy babies dressed as adults. Okay. Where are we?
我很想知道海报里的那两个婴儿是谁。哦，伙计们，他们现在在哪里？如果你是那个婴儿爵士乐海报里的宝宝，请给我们写信。发到 officeladiesatearwolf.com。关于那张婴儿爵士乐海报，我记得迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）告诉我，他们觉得安吉拉会非常喜欢打扮成成年人的婴儿，这非常搞笑。好了。我们讲到哪儿了？
Well, we're talking about the gifts. And Mike Schur actually said that the gifts were incredibly hard to manage because they start off as Secret Santa. So everybody had a person that they bought a specific gift for. And then you had to track the gifts as they went around in the Yankee swap. He actually, in the script of this episode, there is a whole page where he lists the gifts. Who bought who what?
嗯，我们在谈论礼物。迈克·舒尔实际上说过，这些礼物极其难以管理，因为它们是从神秘圣诞老人（Secret Santa）开始的。所以每个人都有一个他们专门为其购买礼物的人。然后你必须追踪这些礼物在白色大象交换（Yankee swap）中的流转过程。事实上，在这集的剧本里，有一整页他列出的礼物清单。谁给谁买什么？
And he did this for Veda, our script supervisor. We haven't really talked about her, but Veda's job is to sit and watch every take that is filmed and make notes about everything that happens continuity wise. So I mean, like really specific. So like, if in a scene, you take a drink of your tea on a certain line and then scratch your nose on another one, Veda writes it down so that you do it the same every time for editing purposes. Yeah.
他这是为我们的剧本监督维达（Veda）做的。我们还没怎么聊过她，但维达的工作是坐下来观看拍摄的每一个镜头，并记录下关于连续性的所有事情。所以我的意思是，非常具体。比如，如果在一个场景中，你在某句台词时喝了一口茶，然后在另一句台词时挠了挠鼻子，维达就会把它记下来，这样为了剪辑的目的，你每次都要做得一模一样。对。
Veda would come up to us and say, Angela, you were holding that pen in your left hand in the first take. And in the second take, you picked it up and held it in your right hand. So that's not going to match. So you need to pick which hand you're going to hold that pen in and do it in every take the same way. Yeah. And in the first place, when you edit it together, the pen is magically bouncing from
维达会走到我们面前说，安吉拉，你在第一个镜头里是用左手拿那支笔的。在第二个镜头里，你把它拿起来用右手拿。所以这不连戏。所以你需要选定你要用哪只手拿那支笔，并且在每一个镜头里都用同样的方式做。对。首先，当你把它们剪辑在一起时，这支笔就会神奇地在
hand to hand. So Mike was really worried about Veda in this episode. And so he made this list just for Veda. And I have it. From the script. Oh, fantastic. Okay. So this is what everyone was intended to give.
两手中跳来跳去。所以迈克在这集里真的很担心维达。因此他专门为维达制作了这份清单。我手里有。来自剧本。哦，太棒了。好的。所以这是原本打算让每个人送出的礼物。
And we got a lot of fan questions about this. Like a lot of people wrote in and said, you know, eventually Michael's going to get the paintball lessons from Dwight. Yeah. So how did Dwight intend that to go to? So I have all the answers right here. Are you ready? Yeah.
我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问。比如很多人写信来说，你知道的，迈克尔最终会从德怀特那里得到彩弹射击课。对。那么德怀特原本打算怎么送出这个呢？所以我这里有所有的答案。准备好了吗？对。
Okay. Dwight got Phyllis, the paintball lessons and the pellets. That was his gift to Phyllis. Phyllis made Michael an oven mitt. Michael got Ryan an iPod. Ryan got Toby a book of short stories by George Saunders, who happens to be one of Mike Sharer's favorite writers. Toby got Angela the baby poster.
好的。德怀特送给菲利丝彩弹射击课和弹丸。那是他送给菲利丝的礼物。菲利丝给迈克尔织了一个隔热手套。迈克尔送给瑞恩一个iPod。瑞恩送给托比一本乔治·桑德斯（George Saunders）的短篇小说集，乔治·桑德斯恰好是迈克·舒尔最喜欢的作家之一。托比送给安吉拉婴儿海报。
Angela bought Stanley a picture frame. Kelly got Kelly a name plate. Kelly got Oscar a shower radio. Oscar got Creed a shamrock key chain. Creed got Jim one of his own shirts. Jim got Pam the teapot. And this is something that got cut out. Pam made Meredith a drawing of the office.
安吉拉给斯坦利买了一个相框。凯利给自己买了一个名牌。凯利送给奥斯卡一个浴室收音机。奥斯卡送给克里德一个三叶草钥匙链。克里德送给吉姆他自己的衬衫之一。吉姆送给帕姆茶壶。这是被删减掉的一个情节。帕姆给梅雷迪思画了一幅办公室的画。
I read about that online. Yeah. And there was this big thing. It's in the deleted scenes. This is something I have to tell you. I got a DVD player for Christmas. What? My husband got me a DVD player.
我在网上读到过这个。Yeah. 还有一个重大事件。它在删减片段里。有一件事我必须告诉你。我圣诞节收到了一台DVD播放机。什么？我丈夫给我买了一台DVD播放机。
So I got the CDs. He bought me the CD set and I got a DVD player and last night I got to watch all the deleted scenes. Oh, Angela. You must be so happy. I was so happy. And there's so many. Oh, yeah.
所以我得到了CD。他给我买了一套CD，我还得到了一个DVD播放机，昨晚我得以观看了所有的删减片段。哦，安吉拉。你一定太高兴了。我太高兴了。而且有那么多。哦，是的。
There's so many. For the Christmas episode, you guys, there are so many great deleted scenes. I don't want to get us off topic here, but they're in the deleted scenes. Meredith opens up her painting. That is from Pam. It's a drawing of the office. Well, there's a big backstory here. Again, with Phil, I don't do Pam's drawings.
有太多了。对于圣诞节那一集，伙计们，有太多精彩的删减片段了。我不想让我们偏离主题，但它们在删减片段里。梅雷迪思打开了她的画。那是来自帕姆的。那是办公室的一幅画。嗯，这里面有一个很大的背景故事。再次提到菲尔，我可不画帕姆的画。
People ask me that all the time. I'm not an artist. I mean, we've talked about this or have we that I do cartoons. I do cartooning. She's very good at cartooning and I have a few that you've drawn that I've saved. I think you're fantastic. Well, I love my little expressive cartoons, but I needed Pam and wanted Pam to be a better artist than I am.
人们总是问我这个。我不是艺术家。我的意思是，我们讨论过这个吗，还是说我画漫画。我画漫画。她在画漫画方面非常厉害，我保留了你画的一些。我觉得你太棒了。嗯，我喜欢我那些小巧、富有表现力的漫画，但我需要并且希望帕姆在艺术上比我更有天赋。
So there is a young art student that does all of Pam's drawings. They went out to a bunch of people, like 12 different artists to turn in samples to be the artist behind Pam and they picked a young woman. Now Jenna, I read, and you can tell me if this is true. I read that the first painting that they had for this episode to give to Meredith from Pam, that they had one of our set art people who was a man do it. And when they looked at it, it looked too masculine. And so then they went out to female artists to have a little bit of a softer touch.
所以有一个年轻的艺术学生负责帕姆的所有画作。他们找了许多人，大约12位不同的艺术家来提交样品，以成为帕姆背后的艺术大师，他们选中了一位年轻女性。现在珍娜，我读到过，你可以告诉我这是否属实。我读到过，他们为这一集准备的第一幅送给梅雷迪思的画是帕姆送的，是由我们的一位男性布景美术人员画的。当他们看这幅画时，它显得太阳刚了。所以他们后来去找了女艺术家来展现一种更柔和的风格。
And there were something like 12 different artists who all submitted their work. And I wish I knew her name. Unfortunately, I don't, but maybe I can find that out and reveal that in a future episode. And then so finally, two more gifts. Both got Dwight, some shot glasses from Cancun and Kevin got himself a foot bath. Guys around five minutes, 55 seconds, there is a scene where Michael is talking to Jim at Jim's desk. This is when he reveals that he got Ryan for Secret Santa.
大约有12位不同的艺术家都提交了他们的作品。我真希望我知道她的名字。不幸的是我不知道，但也许我可以查出来并在以后的节目中揭晓。然后最后，还有另外两份礼物。两人都得到了德怀特送的来自坎昆的一些烈酒杯，凯文给自己买了一个泡脚盆。伙计们，在大约5分55秒的时候，有一个场景是迈克尔在吉姆的办公桌前和吉姆说话。这就是他透露自己在神秘圣诞老人活动中抽到瑞恩的时候。
And I just want to say you see a ton of background action. Angela, you're walking from reception over Steve's shoulder. You see Toby and Mindy talking. Yeah. They are 100% not in character. Not in character at all. I saw that too. I was like, they're just talking about probably something in the writer's room or a story
我只想说，你能看到大量的背景动作。安吉拉，你从前台走过史蒂夫的肩膀后面。你看到托比和曼迪在说话。对。他们百分之百没有在演角色。完全没有在演角色。我也看到了。我想，他们可能只是在讨论编剧室里的什么事情或者一个故事
pitch. Are they just having a conversation? Yeah. I mean, Paul is just being Paul. Yeah. If anyone's curious, the difference between Toby and Paul, go to five minutes, 55 seconds. You can see Paul and Mindy having a conversation in the background. Yeah.
构思。他们只是在聊天吗？对。我的意思是，保罗只是在做他自己。对。如果有人好奇托比和保罗的区别，去看5分55秒。你可以看到保罗和曼迪在背景里聊天。对。
Exactly. Tree lighting. Okay. I have been waiting for this moment. The Christmas tree lighting. This starts the beginning of everyone happy Angela Pist. So, so this Christmas tree, the top of it has been hacked off by Kevin. It is covered in so much tinsel.
没错。点亮圣诞树。好的。我一直在等待这一刻。圣诞树亮灯。这标志着每个人开心、安吉拉抓狂的开始。所以，这棵圣诞树，树顶被凯文砍掉了。上面挂满了金属丝。
Yeah. So much tinsel. It has a smattering of just blue and red ball ornaments. It's just not their best effort. And then it has the tiniest of tiny white lights thanks to Phyllis. So Dwight makes a big deal of it. He like takes the, like the outlet, like the plug, what do you call it? The plug?
对。好多的金属丝。上面零星点缀着一些蓝色和红色的球形装饰品。这实在算不上他们最好的水平。然后多亏了菲利丝，它上面有微乎其微的白色小灯。所以德怀特对此大惊小怪。他拿起了，比如那个电源插座，那个插头，你们叫它什么？插头？
Yeah. He takes the plug from Stanley. He wants to plug it in. He's like, just like Rockefeller Center and everyone gathers around and it's like, brrrrrr. And Phyllis is like, I'm sorry. And it's six minutes, 38 seconds. You see my first pissed off face like, dang it Phyllis. It's also one of those moments where I feel like Angela is like, I knew it.
对。他从斯坦利手里抢过插头。他想把它插上。他说，就像洛克菲勒中心一样，每个人都围了过来，然后就像是，brrrrrr。菲利丝就像是，我很抱歉。在6分38秒时。你看到了我第一张抓狂的脸，就像是，可恶啊菲利丝。这也是那种让我觉得安吉拉在想“我早就知道了”的时刻。
I knew it. I knew I couldn't trust her. Why do I do these lights? Why do I even have her do anything? Why do you have anyone do anything? Yeah. You can't let, and you can't let anyone do anything. These people are worthless.
我早就知道了。我知道我不能信任她。为什么我要让她来弄这些灯？为什么我甚至要让她做任何事？为什么你要让任何人做任何事？对。你不能让，而且你不能让任何人做任何事。这些人毫无用处。
Exactly. Uh, you know that Christmas tree light thing is based on a real thing from Mike Sher's life. I know. He said that when he and his wife got their first tree in New York, he bought a bunch of small lights for the tree and he wrapped them around and when he plugged it in, you couldn't really see them. I love that.
没错。呃，你知道那个圣诞树灯的桥段是根据迈克·舒尔生活中的真实事情改编的吗？我知道。他说当他和妻子在纽约买下他们的第一棵树时，他为这棵树买了一堆小灯，把它们缠绕上去，当他插上电源时，你根本看不清它们。我喜欢这个。
I love when writers work those little moments from their real life into the show. I thought, speaking about people who are acting like themselves instead of their characters, I thought Jim's talking head about Creed's gift is so John. It is John. That is John right there. Yeah. The delivery, the smile, all of it. And then of course, Creed's talking head made me laugh so hard.
我喜欢编剧们把生活中那些小片断融入剧集的时候。我想，说到那些表现得像自己而不是角色的演员，我觉得吉姆关于克里德礼物的访谈（talking head）太有约翰的风格了。这就是约翰。那绝对就是约翰。对。那语气，那微笑，全部都是。然后当然，克里德的访谈让我笑得太厉害了。
Creed is very funny in this episode. I mean, everybody has some great moments, but Creed cracked me up a bunch in this episode. So now Secret Santa is starting. Yep. Everyone is gathered around in some office chairs and I want to say truly, I know we were joking about Charles McDougal, but the amount of energy and movement that he uses the camera to give this scene of people sitting in a circle, I mean, it is impressive from a directorial standpoint.
克里德这一集非常搞笑。我的意思是，每个人都有一些精彩的时刻，但克里德这一集让我笑了好多次。所以现在神秘圣诞老人活动开始了。是的。大家围坐在一些办公椅上，我想说真的，我知道我们在拿查尔斯·麦克道格尔（Charles McDougal）开玩笑，但他用摄像机为这个围坐成一圈的人群场景赋予的能量和运镜，我的意思是，从导演的角度来看，这令人印象深刻。
I think like, I don't want to be crazy, but I think like film students should study this portion of the episode because I'm imagining myself trying to film a group of people sitting in a circle doing a gift exchange and it would not look nearly this dynamic. It's really, really impressive directing. No, he's great. He is really great. Okay. So we're starting the Secret Santa and Pam opens Jim's teapot.
我觉得，我不想表现得太疯狂，但我觉得电影系的学生应该研究这一集的这一部分，因为我想象自己试图拍摄一群人围坐成一圈交换礼物，画面绝对不会显得这么有动态感。这真的是非常非常令人印象深刻的导演功力。不，他很棒。他真的很棒。好的。所以我们开始神秘圣诞老人活动，帕姆打开了吉姆的茶壶。
She loves it, but Dwight moves things along so quickly that she doesn't have time to look inside or notice the card that's in the box. Yeah. Dwight wants no chitty chat between gifts. He's like, go, go, go, go. No. He's me coming in today. He is.
她很喜欢，但德怀特把节奏推进得太快了，以至于她没有时间看里面，也没有注意到盒子里的卡片。对。德怀特希望礼物之间没有任何闲聊。他就像是，快，快，快，快。不。他就像今天刚来的我。他确实是。
He's a Mike. So he's moving things along. So it's Pam. And then the next one, we find out that Michael buys Ryan a video iPod that costs $400. You guys, this was not product placement. It was not. So many people wanted to know. Yeah.
他就像个迈克斯。所以他在推动节奏。所以是帕姆。然后接下来，我们发现迈克尔给瑞恩买了一个价值400美元的视频iPod。伙计们，这不是产品植入。真不是。有那么多人想知道。对。
We were not paid. It was just sort of a really cool topical gift at the time. Yeah. And they were trying to think of a gift that would sort of be a showstopper that Michael would think was very impressive that everyone would want. So this was coincidence. We weren't paid to use it. So I read that that, well, well, here's the something.
我们没有拿钱。这只是当时一个非常酷且符合时事的礼物。对。他们当时想找一件能让人眼前一亮、迈克尔会觉得非常震撼、每个人都会想要的礼物。所以这纯属巧合。我们没有收钱使用它。所以我读到过那，好吧，事情是这样的。
A ton of people wanted to know who kept it at the end. Nobody. We weren't allowed to keep any of the stuff. It all goes into a giant warehouse and it gets labeled for the episode for props because if for some reason we have to go back and reshoot something, they take it off the shelf and they bring it back in. That's true. I don't know what happens after it's been in the warehouse for a while, but it just goes
有成吨的人想知道最后是谁留下了它。没有人。我们不允许保留任何东西。它们全部进入一个巨大的仓库，并被贴上道具剧集的标签，因为如果由于某种原因我们需要回去重拍某些东西，他们会把它从货架上拿下来并带回来。确实如此。我不知道它在仓库里呆了一段时间后会怎么样，但它只是去了
to prop house storage. I feel like it's still in a box labeled the office Christmas party. Probably is. There was a fan question from Beard Up, Beard Down. Was the iPod sponsored by Apple? It wasn't. We said it was not. It's just a total coincidence.
道具仓库储存。我觉得它仍然装在一个贴着“办公室圣诞派对”标签的箱子里。很可能是的。有一个来自“胡须向上，胡须向下”的粉丝提问。iPod是由苹果赞助的吗？不是。我们说过了，没有。这完全是个巧合。
But there's more coincidence. So the week after this episode aired, Apple revealed that you could now download episodes of the office onto these video iPods. Again, this was not planned. And then the office became the number one downloaded show on iTunes. Yes. The number one downloaded show. I remember Rain Wilson turned to me and said, I think we're going to make it.
但还有更多的巧合。所以在这一集播出后的那一周，苹果公司透露，你现在可以将《办公室》的剧集下载到这些视频iPod上。同样，这不是计划好的。然后《办公室》成为了iTunes上下载量第一的节目。是的。下载量第一的节目。我记得雷恩·威尔逊转向我说，我觉得我们要成功了。
I think we're going to. This was the first moment it felt like the tide was turning for us and that we might not get canceled. All right. So next up, Michael gets his gift, the oven mitt knitted by Phyllis. Now everyone had a $20 limit, you guys. That's why this iPod really shakes everything up because he spent $400. Yes.
我觉得我们要。这是第一个让人感觉时来运转、我们可能不会被取消预定的时刻。好了。接下来，迈克尔得到了他的礼物，由菲利丝织的隔热手套。现在每个人都有20美元的预算上限，伙计们。这就是为什么这个iPod彻底打破了一切，因为他花了400美元。是的。
Yes. And he has his line where he says, I only, he says out in the hallway, he's holding the mitt and he says, do you know what this says? This says, I only care about you a homemade oven mitts worth. He is such a child. He is such a bratty kid in this episode. Oh my gosh. Well, we had a fan question from Chelsea, Raccoza and Amanda and many others actually.
是的。而且他有那句台词，他说我只，他在走廊外面说，手里拿着手套说，你知道这说明什么吗？这说明，我对你的在乎只值一副自制的隔热手套。他简直就像个孩子。他在这一集里就像个被宠坏的小屁孩。哦天哪。嗯，我们收到了来自切尔西、拉科扎（Raccoza）和阿曼达以及实际上许多其他人的粉丝提问。
Who actually knitted the oven mitt? Well, I asked Phyllis, she does not knit in real life, although she told me that she knitted a scarf for her mom a couple of years ago, but she said that's it. She didn't. Oh, just one scarf. I want you guys to know, you know how we talk about what was at everyone's desk. So at Phyllis's desk, like sitting on the floor sort of next to her desk for so many years was a whole knitting basket.
究竟是谁织了这副隔热手套？嗯，我问过菲利丝，她现实生活中并不织毛衣，尽管她告诉我几年前她为她妈妈织过一条围巾，但她说就那样。她没有。哦，就一条围巾。我想让你们知道，你知道我们是怎么谈论每个人的办公桌上的东西的吗？所以，在菲利丝的办公桌上，多年来一直放着一个编织篮，就放在她桌子旁边地板上的那种。
Do you remember? I do remember that. It had all the yarn and the knitting needles and it sat there as if her character or whatever do anything with it, but it was established there and it sat there. Well Phyllis Shea told me he found a woman at a knitting store in Valley Village, California and she knitted the oven mitt. Again, oven mitt knitter, if you're listening, please write us at OfficeLadiesAtEarWolf.com and we'll give you a shout out.
你还记得吗？我确实记得。里面有所有的纱线和织针，它就那样放着，就好像她的角色会用它做什么似的，但它就固定在那里，一直放在那儿。嗯，菲利丝·希尔告诉我，他在加利福尼亚州山谷村（Valley Village）的一家毛线店找到了一位女士，她织了这副隔热手套。再次声明，隔热手套的织造者，如果你在听，请写信给我们：OfficeLadiesAtEarWolf.com，我们会向你致谢。
Yeah. Knitted the famous mitt. I thought it looked like a great oven mitt and it had like the little like a, like the Teflon. Teflon anything on the one side. So Ryan gets the iPod and at eight minutes, 24 seconds is the next phase of Angela Pistofness. Okay. You see my face at the fact that Michael spent $400 when the limit was 20.
对。织了那个著名的手套。我觉得它看起来像个很棒的隔热手套，而且它有一点像，比如特氟龙。一侧有特氟龙之类的东西。所以瑞恩拿到了iPod，在8分24秒时，安吉拉抓狂的下一阶段开始了。好的。你看到我的表情了，因为迈克尔在限额20美元的情况下花了400美元。
All of my instructions, I'm sure I sent out an email about Secret Santa and the rules. So one Phyllis has ignored my request for bigger lights and got the tiny lights. Now too, Michael has spent $400 instead of their agreed upon $20. So we're ramping up. She's getting ticked off. I have no doubt that you sent a very detailed email about this to everyone with a follow up reminder. Which is why Kevin does not come forward when he gets himself because he would have had
我所有的指示，我确信我发过一封关于神秘圣诞老人和规则的电子邮件。所以第一，菲利丝忽视了我对更大灯泡的要求，买下了微型灯。现在第二，迈克尔花了400美元，而不是他们商定好的20美元。所以我们的情绪在升级。她被惹恼了。毫无疑问，你为此给每个人发了一封非常详细的电子邮件，并附有后续提醒。这也是为什么凯文在给自己买礼物时不肯站出来的原因，因为他本得
to tell me. He would have. Yeah. You know what? I really relate to Angela on so many levels. Listen. I do. If there's on some levels, you're way more Angela than I am.
告诉我。他本得告诉我的。对。你知道吗？我在很多方面都真的很有共鸣安吉拉。听着。我确实有。如果在某些方面，你比我更像安吉拉。
Oh yeah. I mean, I would have generated two, three, four very detailed emails about the party, the plans. If I assigned someone to do lights for the tree and that's what I got, I would feel so pissed and let down. If people went over the $20 budget, you would have been furious. Furious. Because you would have been like, what's the point?
哦，是的。我的意思是，我会针对派对和计划发出两封、三封、四封非常详细的电子邮件。如果我指派某人去为圣诞树弄灯光，结果得到的就是这个，我会感到非常生气和失望。如果有人超出了20美元的预算，你一定会勃然大怒。怒不可遏。因为你会觉得，意义何在？
Why even have that number? Is Angela wrong? No. I don't think she's wrong. She's just, you know, why is no one helping her? She's a by the book person. Why can't people follow the rules? I agree.
为什么还要设这个数字？安吉拉错了吗？没有。我不认为她错了。她只是，你知道，为什么没有人帮她？她是个循规蹈矩的人。为什么人们就不能遵守规则？我同意。
So at nine minutes, 39 seconds, she gets pissed off on a whole new level because as you were saying, this is when Michael is really ticked off that he got the oven mitt and he switches the party. No more secret, Santa. He says, now we're doing Yankee Swap. Yes. Yankee Swap slash White Elephant slash, what was the other one he said? Nasty Christmas.
所以在9分39秒时，她达到了一个全新高度的愤怒，正如你所说，这就是迈克尔对得到隔热手套感到非常愤怒并改变派对规则的时候。不再是神秘圣诞老人。他说，现在我们玩白色大象交换（Yankee Swap）。是的。白色大象交换斜杠白象（White Elephant）斜杠，他说的另一个是什么？讨厌的圣诞节。
Nasty Christmas. You know, there was actually a little debate about what do you call it? And people were like, well, we call it White Elephant and someone else was like, we call it Yankee Swap. And I feel like the writers took that and put it in the episode. Yeah. I know it as Yankee Swap. What do you know about it?
讨厌的圣诞节。你知道，其实关于你该叫它什么有过一点争论？人们会说，嗯，我们叫它白象，另一个人会说，我们叫它Yankee Swap。我觉得编剧们采用了这一点并把它放进了剧集里。对。我知道它叫Yankee Swap。你对它了解多少？
I knew it as White Elephant. Yeah. I think it's good they did that. I do too. They covered everybody. They covered everybody. But when I threw my Christmas party, I called it Yankee Swap just because I loved it so much.
我知道它叫白象。对。我觉得他们这样做很好。我也这么觉得。他们照顾到了所有人。他们照顾到了所有人。但当我举办自己的圣诞派对时，我叫它Yankee Swap，纯粹是因为我太喜欢它了。
You know, here's something that I heard in the commentary, Angela, since we're talking about your character. I guess that you had a talking head in the fire. I watched it because I have a DVD player now. Where you cry. Yes. In the deleted scenes. Well, Mike said that the writer's room was so impressed with your performance and that
你知道，安吉拉，既然我们在谈论你的角色，我从评论音轨里听到了这样一件事。我猜你在火灾里有一段访谈。我看了，因为我现在有一台DVD播放机。你哭了。是的。在删减片段里。嗯，迈克说编剧室对你的表演印象深刻，而且对那个
talking head that they put a card on the wall that was Angela cries. And they wanted to find an episode where you could cry a bunch. And this was it. Mike told me he said, I love to see your character cry. He said she's so pulled together that when you sort of fall apart, it's like really sort of oddly pleasing. Oh, I love it. I love it.
访谈，他们在墙上贴了一张卡片，上面写着“安吉拉哭了”。他们想找一集你能大哭一场的剧集，而这就是这一集。迈克告诉我，他说，我喜欢看你的角色哭。他说她平时太镇定了，以至于当你某种程度上崩溃时，看起来真的有一种奇异的愉悦感。哦，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。
So yes, at nine minutes, 51 seconds, I have a talking head and my character is really upset because she feels like Michael should have talked to the PPC first. Yeah. Well, they should have. And then she should have. And then she breaks down. So she is, she is really starting to spiral. And then when we cut back to the scene, she's still sobbing.
所以是的，在9分51秒时，我有一个访谈，我的角色真的很沮丧，因为她觉得迈克尔应该先和PPC（派对策划委员会）商量。对。嗯，他们本来就应该商量。然后她应该。然后她崩溃了。所以她，她真的开始陷入失控的螺旋。然后当我们切回那个场景时，她还在抽泣。
I mean, she's not sobbing, but she's still crying. She's sullen. She's very sullen. Okay. You know this famous line, Yankee swap. Yeah. From Michael. All right.
我的意思是，她不是在嚎啕大哭，但她还在哭。她闷闷不乐。她非常闷闷不乐。好的。你知道这句名言，Yankee swap。对。出自迈克尔之口。好吧。
Mike, sure. That's a written line that wasn't improvised that Steve would say Yankee swap. And Mike wrote in the script in parentheses, crazy voice. And he, he was like, I know Steve will do something great with that. And that was Steve's take on that because they would do that. They would sometimes put little pieces of direction in the script for us. And then we'd have to interpret it. Yeah.
迈克·舒尔。那是台词里写好的，并不是即兴发挥史蒂夫会说Yankee swap。迈克在剧本的括号里写道：疯狂的声音。而且他当时想，我知道史蒂夫会用这个发挥得很棒。这就是史蒂夫对那句话的演绎，因为他们会这样做。他们有时会在剧本里为我们加上一点表演指导。然后我们就得去解读它。对。
Guys, did you notice in this episode, it is snowing outside? I loved this touch. I love that they kept cutting to the windows and there'd be snow. Do you remember how much fun it was to have the snow? We were so tickled. We were so excited. You guys remember we mostly just filmed inside and we never even saw outside or what was happening outside.
伙计们，你们注意到在这集里，外面在下雪吗？我喜欢这个细节。我喜欢他们不断切到窗户，外面都会有雪。你还记得下雪有多好玩吗？我们太高兴了。我们太兴奋了。你们还记得吗，我们大部分时间都只在室内拍摄，甚至从未看到外面或外面发生了什么。
Yeah. And so the fact that we had this extra element happening was so fun. We really did film inside in a windowless warehouse. All the windows were fake. They just had backdrops behind them. Yeah. So to see actual sunshine or snow or air was really exciting to us. I have a ton of facts about the snow.
对。所以我们有这个额外的元素发生，这太有趣了。我们确实是在一个没有窗户的仓库里室内拍摄的。所有的窗户都是假的。它们后面只有背景幕。对。所以看到真正的阳光、雪或空气对我们来说真的令人兴奋。我有很多关于雪的事实。
I don't know if anyone else will find it interesting, but I had written all about it in one of my blogs slash journals. I'm living for this. I can't wait to hear about it. All right. I do have to pee. Oh, do you want me to give you some snow facts when we come back from the break? I mean, can I?
我不知道其他人会不会觉得有趣，但我把它全部写在我的博客/日记里了。我太期待这个了。我等不及要听了。好吧。我确实得去尿尿。哦，你想让我等我们从休息回来后告诉你一些关于雪的事实吗？我的意思是，我可以吗？
You should be on an empty bladder when I lay these awesome facts on you. You don't tell me or my bladder what we're doing. Well, what do you want? Do you want full bladder snow facts or empty bladder snow facts? I want empty bladder snow facts. All right. That's what I'm saying. Oh, I thought you were telling me that I had to not drink any more water or tea.
当我把这些惊人的事实抛给你时，你的膀胱应该排空。你不要告诉我或我的膀胱我们在做什么。好吧，你想要什么？你想要满膀胱的雪的事实，还是空膀胱的雪的事实？我想要空膀胱的雪的事实。好的。这就是我要说的。哦，我还以为你是在告诉我，我不能再喝任何水或茶了。
When we go on a road trip. What? Can you not get a nice tea? Okay. Clearly you're projecting some other thing on me because I said I thought you should empty your bladder for the snow facts. She's leaving first. You push away from the mic to eat your, your snack.
当我们去公路旅行时。什么？你就不能喝杯好茶吗？很明显，你把别的什么情绪投射到我身上了，因为我说过我觉得你应该为雪的事实排空膀胱。她先走了。你推开麦克风去吃你的，你的零食。
This is for you, Jenna. So disgusting. Those are high-nut Cheerios. Oh God. Thank you for letting me have my bathroom break. I want to hear all about your snow. All right. I hope this isn't anticlimactic for people, but the company that came to make the snow
这是给你的，珍娜。太恶心了。那是高坚果谷物圈。哦天哪。谢谢你让我去上厕所。我想听听你关于雪的一切。好吧。我希望这对大家来说不是反高潮，但那家来造雪的公司
is called Snow Business. I love that. Snow business. Snow business. I remembered. I remembered that. It's so tickled me. Okay.
叫做“造雪业务”（Snow Business）。我喜欢这个。造雪业务。造雪业务。我记住了。我记住了。这太让我开心了。好的。
So here's how it works with fake snow. There's a guy from Snow Business. He shows up. Now the snow that falls from the sky is different from the ground cover snow. The snow on the ground is snow. The snow that falls from the sky, I know because it falls on my character at the end and it is not snow. It's not snow.
所以假雪是这样运作的。有一个来自“造雪业务”的人。他出现了。现在，从天上落下的雪和地上的积雪是不一样的。地上的雪就是雪。从天上落下的雪，我知道是因为它最后落在了我的角色身上，这不是雪。这不是雪。
It's soap. Yes. You can get a choice. You can get a choice of cornstarch, plastic, or soap. And Greg watched a demonstration of all three and he picked soap. Well, when by accident a little piece of that might get in your mouth, it's like soap because I shriek and I piece of it went in my mouth. That's what she said.
是肥皂。是的。你可以有选择。你可以选择玉米淀粉、塑料或肥皂。格雷格（Greg）观看了这三种材料的演示，他选择了肥皂。当一点那种东西不小心进到你嘴里时，就像肥皂一样，因为我尖叫了，有一小块进到了我嘴里。这就是她说的。
Yeah. Okay. On the ground though, it's real snow and they bring this machine and I don't know exactly how it works, but it's kind of like a wood chipper, but in reverse. It looks like something out of a Dr. Seuss. It does. It really does. And it really blows snow.
是的。好的。不过在地上，那是真正的雪，他们带了这台机器，我不知道它具体是怎么运作的，但它有点像碎木机，不过是反向的。它看起来像是苏斯博士（Dr. Seuss）作品里的东西。确实如此。真的挺像。而且它真的能吹出雪。
I guess that's what it looks like. It looks like a snowblower, but it generates snow and then it just blows it all over the ground, all over the cars and all that stuff. But guys, remember, this is like, we're shooting this in like October in Los Angeles and it's hot in October. It stays warm here in the daytime. It's still in the mid-80s, 90s, but it was night and so we had a little bit of time with it.
我想这就是它的样子。它看起来像个吹雪机，但它能造出雪，然后把它吹到地面上、汽车上以及所有这些东西上。但伙计们，记住，这就像，我们是在10月份在洛杉矶拍摄的，10月份天气很热。这里白天一直很暖和。气温仍然在80多度、90度左右，但那是晚上，所以我们有一点时间使用它。
It was a little warm out, but it was probably like in the high 60s. Yeah. That sounds about right. All right. Yes. We were very excited to have snow and Jenna, we're... Did you like my snow facts? I love...
外面有点暖和，但可能在60多度的高温吧。对。听起来差不多。好的。是的，我们对有雪感到非常兴奋，珍娜，我们……你喜欢我的雪的事实吗？我喜欢……
I feel a little vulnerable about them now because we set them up so much. I mean, there was like a break and then my head about it. I like your snow facts. Snow business. That's cute. I think snow business is really cute. All right. Let's go back to the gift exchange.
我现在对它们感到有点脆弱，因为我们之前铺垫了那么多。我的意思是，中间隔了一场休息，然后还有我的访谈。我喜欢你的雪的事实。造雪业务。真可爱。我觉得造雪业务真的很可爱。好吧。让我们回到礼物交换。
This is when Kelly gets Angela's poster, but Angela, you do get to take it back. Okay. Here's the thing. I wrote in my space blog about this moment and I wrote that it was one of the hardest things for us to get through as a cast that the first time Mindy unrolls the poster and looks at it and we all see it, we all, every person lost it. Because it's so ridiculous. It's so ridiculous.
这就是凯利拿到安吉拉的海报的时候，但是安吉拉，你确实把它拿回来了。好的。事情是这样的。我在我的太空博客（space blog）上写过这个时刻，我写道，这是我们作为演员最难挺过去的时刻之一，当曼迪第一次展开海报并看着它，我们所有人都看到了，我们所有人都，每个人都笑场了。因为这太荒谬了。这太荒谬了。
I had not seen it. It was an actual surprise to us while we were filming and we all lost it. I had that in fact, it was particularly hard on Rain for some reason and that in one take he broke three times because he could not get through it. I can't believe that Mindy was tasked with having to unroll that poster. How did we ever get a shot of her not laughing? I don't know, but we were cracking up. There's a little detail in that scene that made me laugh when I rewatched it, which is
我没见过它。我们在拍摄时这实际上是一个惊喜，我们所有人都笑崩了。事实上，不知为什么，这对雷恩来说尤其艰难，在其中一个镜头里他NG了三次，因为他根本无法演下去。我真不敢相信曼迪的任务竟然是不得不展开那张海报。我们到底是怎么拍到她不笑的镜头的？我不知道，但我们当时笑疯了。那个场景里有一个小细节在我重看时逗笑了我，那就是
how you just very subtly swat the oven mitt away on your way to getting the poster. That was all me. Thank you very much. I loved it. It was such a good detail. I loved it. In tracking the oven mitt, Meredith eventually takes the oven mitt, but Michael has to then call her a sucker and say that he wanted her to take it and it was reverse psychology when
你在去拿海报的路上，是怎样非常巧妙地把隔热手套拍开的。那全是我自己设计的。非常感谢。我太喜欢了。那真是个很好的细节。在追踪隔热手套的过程中，梅雷迪思最终拿走了隔热手套，但迈克尔随后不得不叫她冤大头，并说他本来就想让她拿走，当
he said he wanted to keep it. I love that he decided that he needed to break down reverse psychology to all of us because I don't know if you've heard of it. This is a pretty cool thing. Michael, you're such an idiot. Do you remember how Phyllis cried during that scene? Yeah, she stayed in that sad place. She cried for a half hour and in between takes of that where she had to be crying.
他说他想留着它时这其实是反向心理学。我喜欢他决定向我们所有人都解析一下反向心理学，因为我不知道你们有没有听说过这个。这是一件挺酷的事情。迈克尔，你真是个白痴。你还记得菲利丝在那场戏里是怎么哭的吗？对，她一直沉浸在那种悲伤的情绪里。她哭了半个小时，在必须哭泣的镜头间隙。
She didn't want any of us to talk to her and Kate and I tried to go up and give her a hug. She didn't want it like she was in this like actor zone. It's so hard to do. It's so hard to do. I know exactly where she was, but I just remember being really worried for her because when you see Phyllis cry, it is, ugh. You don't want to see Phyllis cry because it breaks every part of you open. I mean, she had to stay sad and it is really hard, especially sitting in this circle with
她不想让我们任何人跟她说话，凯特和我试着走过去给她一个拥抱。她不希望这样，就像她进入了一种演员的“禁区”状态。这太难做到了。这太难做到了。我完全懂她的感受，但我只记得当时真的很替她担心，因为当你看到菲利丝哭的时候，那是，呃。你不想看到菲利丝哭，因为它会撕裂你身体的每一个部分。我的意思是，她必须保持悲伤，这真的很难，特别是坐在这个围成一圈、大家都在因为一张婴儿海报而笑得前仰后合的人中间，但你必须保持悲伤。是的。这很难。这真的很难。这非常困难。嗯，事情是这样的。迈克尔变得越来越刻薄。他叫梅雷迪思冤大头，然后德怀特，他打开了彩弹礼盒，然后就像，呃。
people cracking up about a baby poster, but you've got to stay sad. Yes. It's hard. It's really hard. It's very difficult. Well, here's the thing. Michael just gets progressively meaner. He calls Meredith a sucker and then Dwight, he opens the paintball and he's like, ugh.
这怎么能比得上iPod呢，当德怀特说“我从来没说过它更好”时，这个时刻也让我有点心碎。你知道吗？等等，我这里有一个安吉拉抓狂的时刻。好的，说吧。在13分58秒，看我的脸。我用全大写字母写下来了。所以迈克尔刚刚因为梅雷迪思拿了那个蹩脚的隔热手套而叫她冤大头，然后菲利丝
How is this better than an iPod and this moment kind of broke my heart too when Dwight goes, I never said it was better. You know? Wait, I have an Angela pissed off in this moment. Okay, go. At 13 minutes, 58 seconds, look at my face. I wrote it in all caps. So Michael has just called Meredith a sucker because she got the lame oven mitt and Phyllis
夺门而出。好的。她现在彻底心碎了，派对正在分崩离析。嗯。而我脸上的表情纯粹是愤怒。现在，我们达到你愤怒的顶点了吗？没有。哦，没有。
storms out. Okay. She was completely heartbroken now and the party is falling apart. Mm-hmm. And the look on my face is just sheer and like rage. Now, are we at the top of your rage now? No. Oh, no.
好吧，我的意思是，我知道我们还有停车场，但是——没有。哦，没有。有一个时刻即将来临，你会认出来的。那是，最后有一记组合拳，是为了我的愤怒。但是是的。好吧。所以人们在做交易，感情受到了伤害。
Well, I mean, I know we've still got the parking lot, but- No. Oh, no. There's a moment coming and you'll know it. It's the, there's a one, two punch coming at the end for my anger. But yeah. All right. So people are making trades and feelings are getting hurt.
是的。而且帕姆没有回去拿茶壶。她拿了iPod。她确实拿了。当轮到帕姆再次挑选时，她选了iPod而不是茶壶，吉姆太受伤了。他太受伤了。而且我，你知道，我看了这个然后我想，拜托，帕姆。
Yeah. And Pam does not go back and get the teapot. She gets the iPod. She does. When it's Pam's turn to pick again, she picks the iPod instead of the teapot and Jim is so hurt. He's so hurt. And I, you know, I watched this and I was like, come on, Pam.
但后来，你知道，帕姆并不知道茶壶里有什么。她不知道。这就是为什么这对我来说合情合理的原因。她只是觉得，这是一个iPod。这个iPod彻底劫持了这个有趣的派对和礼物交换，因为每个坐在座位上的人都只想试图得到这个iPod。帕姆也是如此。不幸的是，我想她有点把茶壶给忘了。
But then, you know, Pam doesn't know what all is in the teapot. She doesn't. And that's what sort of justified it for me. She's just like, this is an iPod. This iPod has completely hijacked this whole fun party and gift exchange because everybody who's sitting in the seat is just thinking about trying to get this iPod. And so is Pam. Unfortunately, I think she kind of forgot about the teapot.
所以轮到她选的时候。她就觉得：iPod。但她也不知道茶壶里装的是什么。她不知道。她不知道这对吉姆来说赌注有多高。她不知道。老实说，我觉得这是一个很天真的时刻。而且迈克尔把这一切都毁了，因为这些礼物原本是专门为特定的人准备的。
So it was her time to pick. She was just like, iPod. But she also doesn't know what's in the teapot. She doesn't. She doesn't know how high the stakes are for Jim. She doesn't. I think it's kind of an innocent moment, honestly. And Michael has ruined all of this because the gifts were specific for people.
我的意思是，瑞恩得到了一块写着“凯利”的铭牌。他得到了一块，你知道的，桌子名牌什么的。这些根本不是为了当做白色大象交换礼物准备的。它们本不是。它们是给特定的人准备的。嗯，在这个时候，派对已经彻底崩溃了，迈克尔去了酒品店。现在我想指出几件事。
I mean, Ryan gets a placard that says Kelly. He gets like, you know, a desk, whatever, name plate. Like these were not meant to be Yankee swap gifts. They were not. They were meant for certain people. Well, at this point, the party has completely broken down and Michael goes to the liquor store. Now I want to point out a few things.
我知道你要指出什么，因为大姐，我现在有DVD了。所以说吧。你知道我要说什么吗？是关于酒品店售货员的事吗？我有一件事要说，但我只是想指出，酒品店窗外也在下雪。对。他们在那里也造了雪。
I know what you're going to point out because lady, I have the DVDs now. So go do it. Do you know what I'm going to say? Is it about the attendant at the liquor store? I have one thing to say about him, but I just thought I wanted to point out that it's also snowing outside the window of the liquor store. Yeah. They made it snow there, too.
嗯。不知道。不错的细节。不错的点缀。很好的连戏。维达对这个抓得很紧。嗯，我读到过我们的编剧发现在宾夕法尼亚州，如果你在酒品店工作，你必须戴领带。
Mm-hmm. I don't know. Nice detail. Nice touch. Good continuity. Veta was on it. Well, I read that our writers found out in Pennsylvania that if you work at a liquor store, you have to wear a tie.
是的。所以那是该角色设定的一部分，他必须戴着领带。不是很棒吗？而且我觉得那个演员，他叫瑞安·马丁（Ryan Martin），表现得太棒了。他只是真的，把所有的伏特加都拿下了。那是15瓶，15瓶。疯狂。好的。
Yes. And so that was part of this character description is that he had to have on a tie. Isn't that great? And I thought the actor, his name is Ryan Martin, did a fantastic job. He just really like takes in all of that vodka. It's just 15 bottles, 15 bottles. Craziness. Okay.
所以然后我们回到了派对。迈克尔把所有的伏特加都带回了派对，时间是16分10秒。这是安吉拉情绪失控螺旋的下一阶段。哦，说吧。所以迈克尔带了伏特加，她就像是，你在干什么？派对上没有酒精。你知道的，安吉拉开口了，托比也开口了。其他人根本不在乎。
So then we go back to the party. Michael brings all this vodka back into the party and it's 16, 10 minutes. This is the next phase of Angela, Angela's spiral. Oh, say it. So Michael has vodka and she's like, what are you doing? There's no alcohol at the party. You know, Angela speaks up and Toby speaks up. No one else cares.
但现在她就像是：托比开口了。我漏掉了这个。对。托比就像是，迈克尔，我们真的不应该有，然后走开了。闭嘴吧。托比。这可是派对。但后来我觉得托比给托德·帕克（Todd Packer）拿了一杯饮品。
But now she's like, Toby speaks up. I miss that. Yeah. Toby's like, Michael, we really shouldn't have any goes. Just shut it. Toby. It's a party. But then later I feel like Toby brings Todd Packer a drink.
嗯，不，这一切，所有的规矩到这里都烟消云散了，而且，你知道，你必须记住，迈克尔曾对派对策划委员会说过，他希望这个圣诞派对办得像，我引述一下，“花花公子庄园派对”。对。那是他的期望。那是他的目标。那是他的目标。是的，安吉拉现在超级抓狂，因为现在有酒了。
Well, no, it's all, all like, all that's off at this point and, and you know, you have to remember that Michael told the party planning committee that he wanted this Christmas party to be like, and I quote, a playboy mansion party. Yeah. That was his hope. That's his goal. That's his goal. Yeah, Angela is now super ticked because now there's alcohol.
我很惊讶她的整个脑袋居然没有爆炸。嗯，它快要爆炸了，因为接下来这两件事才是真正点燃导火索的原因。哦天哪。好吧，现在我们有了吉姆试图从德怀特那里拿回茶壶的场景。吉姆主动提出拿三叶草钥匙链跟他交换，他说，来吧，这会带来好运的。然后德怀特说出了那句台词。真男人创造属于自己的运气，比利·赞恩，《泰坦尼克号》和安吉拉。你为全体演员制作了印有这句台词的T恤，我现在还留着呢。
I'm surprised her whole head didn't explode. Well, it's about to, because the next two are what set it set it into motion. Oh boy. Well, now we have the scene where Jim is trying to get the teapot back from Dwight. Jim offers to trade him the shamrock key chain and he says, come on, it'll be good luck. And that's when Dwight has his line. A real man makes his own luck, Billy Zane, Titanic and Angela. You made the entire cast t-shirts with that quote on them and I still have mine.
哦天哪。你真的留着。我有。那是件灰色的长袖T恤。是的。上面就印着那句台词。对。所以当时我有个朋友有一台T恤印花机，因为她有一家小企业，而且
Oh my gosh. You do. I do. It's a gray long sleeve t-shirt. Yes. And it's just a quote across it. Yeah. So I had a friend at the time who had a t-shirt press because she had a small business and
我太喜欢这句台词了。我觉得德怀特能引用这句话简直太搞笑了。居然会是比利·赞恩。嗯，人们一直在问我们是否互送礼物。那是一件礼物。那是你送的。我想你当年确实是在圣诞节送了这个。我确实送了。
I loved this line so much. I thought it was hilarious of all people for Dwight to quote. It would be Billy Zane. Well, people were asking if we gave each other gifts. That was a gift. You gave that out. I think you actually gave that out at Christmas that year. I did.
而且你送了每个人一个装饰品。是的。我拿到了那张演员合影，并把它印在每个人的一员装饰品上。Yep. 噢。德怀特想留着茶壶以便用绿茶冲洗鼻腔的想法，是基于格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）实际做过的事情。就像用洗鼻壶（neti pot）那样？
And you gave everyone an ornament. Yes. I got that cast photo and I had it printed on an ornament for everyone. Yep. Aw. The idea that Dwight wants to keep the teapot in order to wash out his nasal passages with green tea is based on something that Greg Daniels has actually done. Like with a neti pot?
对。我的意思是，但我从来没有在洗鼻壶里放过绿茶。我也没有。我只用过推荐的生理盐水溶液。但我能想象格雷格读到过这个并尝试了一下。不过雷恩，雷恩在那个场景里的表现，他把那个茶壶塞进自己的鼻孔里。而吉姆——也就是约翰的脸——简直就像是：你在跟我开玩笑吗？这就是得到我茶壶的人。
Yeah. I mean, but I've never put green tea in a neti pot. I haven't either. I've only used the saline solution that is recommended. But I could see Greg reading about it and giving it a try. But rain, the way rain was in that scene and he like shoved that teapot into his nostril. And just John's face's gym is just like, are you kidding me? That's who gets my teapot.
是的。我的意思是，但我从来没有把绿茶放进洗鼻壶里。我也没有。我只用推荐的生理盐水。但我能想象格雷普读到这个然后去尝试一下。但是雨，那个场景里的雨，他把茶壶塞进鼻孔里的样子。而约翰的表情就像是在说，你在开玩笑吗？这就是得到我茶壶的人。
It's so perfect. He's so bummed. Now, when I watched this with Lee, Lee said he wondered how Dwight didn't find the note in the box or how Dwight didn't open up the teapot. I thought of all of those things. I thought Dwight now has the cassette and the sauce packet. Yeah. I mean, so you have to sort of suspend belief, I guess, at that moment that he took those
太完美了。他太沮丧了。现在，当我跟李一起看这一集时，李说他很好奇德怀特怎么没在盒子里找到便条，或者德怀特怎么没把茶壶打开。我想到了所有这些。我想德怀特现在有了磁带和酱料包。对啊。我的意思是，所以你大概得暂时停止怀疑，我想，就在那一刻，他把那些
out and just shoved him aside like, hmm, what's this crap? And just sort of shoved him aside in the box. Well, also, I don't think Jim is trying to get the teapot back for Pam. I think he's just trying to get the teapot back for himself. He's just going to keep it now. That's what I think the motivation is there because Pam is over, you know, up at the desk with Roy looking through her new iPod. I think Jim just wants to get it back because I think there's things inside it that are
拿出来，直接随手一扔，就好像，嗯，这是什么垃圾？然后就把它们随手扔在盒子里。嗯，还有，我不觉得吉姆是想把茶壶拿回来给帕姆。我觉得他只是想把茶壶拿回来留给自己。他现在打算把它留着了。我觉得这就是那里的动机，因为帕姆当时正在，你知道的，在前台和罗伊一起看她的新iPod。我觉得吉姆只是想把它拿回来，因为我觉得里面有些东西是
embarrassing. Yes, exactly. But he's going to trade the key chain and he's just going to take that teapot home now. So Pam is up at reception and she's showing Roy her new iPod. He's now at the party. He wasn't there for Yankee Swap, but he's all excited because now he doesn't have to buy it for Pam for Christmas. He was going to buy her this iPod, he tells her.
令人尴尬的。没错，完全是这样。但他打算用钥匙链换，现在他要把那个茶壶带回家了。所以帕姆在前台，她正在向罗伊展示她的新iPod。他现在也来派对现场了。他刚才没来玩“洋基换宝”，但他现在很兴奋，因为他现在不用给帕姆买圣诞礼物了。他本来要给她买这个iPod的，他告诉她。
And now he doesn't have to or he's just going to get her a sweater. Thanks, Roy. Now the party is like 15 bottles of vodka in. Todd Packer has showed up. Oh, yeah. It's getting crazy and... Everyone's doing shots. Angela's fuming.
现在他不用买了，或者他打算随便给她买件毛衣。谢谢你啊，罗伊。现在派对上的伏特加大概已经喝掉15瓶了。托德·帕克也来了。哦，对啊。场面开始疯狂了……每个人都在干杯。安吉拉气坏了。
I am fuming, but the icing on the cake of my pissed off-ness is about to happen. Oh, say it. Michael shouts to the whole bullpen. He says, oh my gosh, yes, Ryan, the king of the party planning. Thank you to Ryan for this awesome party. And the camera pans to me and I am livid. Ryan, the temp, the king of the party planning committee. Are you kidding me?
我是气炸了，但让我火上浇油的事马上就要发生了。哦，说来听听。迈克尔冲着整个开放式办公区大喊。他说，哦天哪，没错，瑞恩，派对策划之王。感谢瑞恩办了这么棒的派对。然后镜头摇向我，我气得脸都绿了。瑞恩，这个临时工，派对策划委员会之王？你在开玩笑吧？
Yeah. Oh, that's it. She is pissed. Oh no. And it's only going to get worse. That's not even still the worst thing that's happened to Angela. Nope. I had a headache by the end of this episode.
对啊。哦，就是这样。她气疯了。哦不。而且情况只会更糟糕。这甚至还不是发生在安吉拉身上最糟糕的事。才不是呢。这集看到最后我都头疼了。
You must have. You were just scowling and pushing anger out of your temples this whole episode. You know when Todd Packer shows up and he has that line, what's up, my nerds? That was an improv sort of. In the script, what was written was what's up, nerds, and he just gave it that extra special touch of what's up, my nerds. I know. Well, that's also Dave Keckner.
你肯定头疼。整集里你都在黑着脸，太阳穴都气得直冒青筋。你知道托德·帕克出场时有句台词是，最近怎么样，我的书呆子们？那其实有点即兴发挥。剧本里写的是，最近怎么样，书呆子们，而他只是加上了特别的点缀，变成“最近怎么样，我的书呆子们”。我懂。好吧，那也是戴夫·科克纳。
I mean, I think even the line when he's like, pack or need a drinkie. The line was probably like, he was getting me a drink, you know? He brought so much to that role. It was amazing. Well, you know when he has to lay down on the desk and get the silly string on him, like when he passes out, I remember shooting that he had to lay there forever. So he laid down on those desks, which were not comfortable, right? And then they silly stringed his head and then we had all these scenes where that's
我是说，我觉得甚至连他说“帕克需要来杯酒吗”那句台词也是。那台词可能就像是，他要给我买杯酒，你知道的？他为那个角色注入了太多东西。太棒了。好吧，你知道当他得躺在办公桌上，身上被喷满彩带，就像他喝醉昏过去那样，我记得拍那场戏时他必须一直在那儿躺着。所以他躺在那些桌子上，一点也不舒服，对吧？然后他们把彩带喷在他头上，接着我们拍的所有戏都是他在做这个。
what he's doing. Well, if he got up, all the stuff that he was decorated in would have fallen off. It would have been impossible to recreate. So he had to just lay there, even when we were on a break, even when we were on a break. And he was such a trooper. Talk about a trooper, and I wrote in my MySpace blog that Kate and I, because Kate and I knew Dave from Improv Days, we'd all like done improv shows together, that Kate and I walked over and talked to him while he had to lay on the back, and we just sort of like caught
好吧，如果他站起来，他身上那些装饰的东西就会掉下来。那就没办法重现了。所以他只能躺在那儿，甚至在我们休息的时候，甚至在我们休息的时候也是。而且他真的很配合。说到配合，我在我的MySpace博客里写过，凯特和我，因为凯特和我从即兴表演时期就认识戴夫了，我们以前一起做过即兴表演秀，所以凯特和我走过去跟他聊天，当时他正躺在背上，我们就是那种叙旧，看到他真的太好玩了。但我希望你们大家知道，如果你想知道托德·帕克在20分19秒时是什么样子，为了在这里描绘出画面，他正仰面躺在房间正中央的一个办公区隔板上。他的头上缠着蓝色的彩带，躯干上缠着圣诞彩灯，躯干上还缠着圣诞花环，肚子上放着德怀特的桌上名牌，而且还有一个红色的空塑料红杯，就夹在他的手臂弯里。他不得不顶着身上所有这些东西那样躺着。
up and that it was so fun to see him. But I want you guys to know, if you're wondering what Todd Packer looks like at 20 Minutes and 19 Seconds, to really paint a picture here, he's laying on his back kind of across a desk area partition right in the middle of the room. He has blue silly string on his head, Christmas lights around his torso, Christmas garland around his torso, Dwight's desk nameplate on his stomach, and there's like a red empty solo cup kind of just like in his, like the crook of his arm. And he had to lay like that with all those things on top of him.
他晕倒得太快了，你一定能想象他来的时候就已经半醉了。你知道他绝对是。你知道他绝对是。你知道他绝对是。好了各位，现在我们看到这场戏是帕姆向吉姆透露她把茶壶拿回来了。她用iPod从德怀特那里换回了茶壶，现在她要打开看看里面所有的东西，这非常迷人且甜蜜，她高兴极了。
He passes out so quickly, you have to imagine he showed up already half drunk. You know he did. You know he did. You know he did. Okay guys, so now we have the scene where Pam reveals to Jim that she got her teapot back. She trades Dwight the iPod for the teapot, and now she's going to look inside and find all the items, and it's very charming and sweet, and she is so delighted.
但就在这时，吉姆偷偷把便条拿回来放进了自己口袋。我知道，他当时怂了。确实如此。现在，当我们联系粉丝询问他们想了解关于圣诞特别集的什么内容时，我想说，我们收到的大约80%的评论和邮件都类似于“茶壶便条里写了什么”。因为如你们所知，在这集里，帕姆并没有读它，内容也没有被揭晓。但是后来，在第九季里，有一个场景是吉姆让纪录片摄制组把他们浪漫过往的素材剪辑在一起，
But in this moment, Jim secretly steals the note back and puts it in his pocket. I know, he lost his courage. He did. Now, when we reached out to fans to ask them what they wanted to know about the Christmas episode, I would say that about 80% of the comments and emails we received were along the lines of what is in the teapot note. Because as you know, in this episode, Pam does not read it, it is not revealed. But then, in season nine, there's a scene where Jim has the documentary film crew put
然后他把这个放给帕姆看，帕姆看到里面有一张吉姆偷偷拿回来的便条，接着他把它递给她，她读了上面的内容。这太绝了，而且你知道那是谁的手笔，那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯，因为他在这种美好的呼应桥段上简直是个大师。我太喜欢了。好吧，自从吉姆偷走那张便条以来，大家就一直好奇得发狂。他们总是想知道便条里写了什么，帕姆以后还能拿到这张便条吗？一年又一年，他以后还会把便条给她吗？
together footage of their romance, and he shows it to Pam, and Pam sees that there was a note that Jim steals back, and then he hands it to her, and she reads it. How brilliant is that, and you know who that is, that's Greg Daniels, because he was such a master at beautiful callback moments. I love that. Well, from the time that Jim stole the note, it drove people crazy. They always wanted to know what had been written in the note, would Pam ever get the note? For years and years, will he ever give her the note?
在他们婚礼前后，人们希望他把这作为结婚礼物送给她。格雷格把它留到了最后。我要说一件我从未说过的事，我还觉得自己可能要哭了。什么？等等。等等。什么？
Around the time of the wedding, people wanted him to give it to her as a wedding gift. Greg saved it till the end. I'm going to say something that I've never said before, I also feel like I'm maybe going to cry. What? Wait. Wait. What?
你要说便条里写了什么吗？你要说便条里写了什么吗？算是吧。因为我不知道那张卡片上写了什么，我们谁也不知道。只有我和约翰知道。哦天哪，蕾迪。在第九季的那集里，我相信格雷格曾向约翰建议，让他写一条他自己对我的私人寄语，就写我们在办公室共度的时光对他的意义。
Are you going to say what was in the note? Are you going to say what was in the note? Sort of. Because I don't know what was on that card, none of us do. I'm the only one who knows, and John knows. Oh my gosh, lady. In that episode in season nine, I believe Greg suggested to John that he write a personal message from himself to me, just saying what our time together on the office meant to him.
因为我们当时正在杀青，我们正在完成这部剧的拍摄，而且我们当时都非常情绪化，你知道吗？我们都在以不同的方式告别。我们确实是。所以那就是他的告别。非常类似于我们和史蒂夫拍那场戏的时候，我在机场向他告别，保罗·菲格告诉我，直接跑过去跟你的朋友史蒂夫说再见。杰夫·布里茨我和奥斯卡在车里时也对我说过同样的话。
Because we were wrapping up filming, we were wrapping up the series, and we were all so emotional at that time, you know? We were all sort of saying goodbye in different ways. We were. And so that was his goodbye. Very similar to when we filmed that scene with Steve, where I said goodbye to him at the airport, and Paul Feig told me, just run up and say goodbye to your friend, Steve. Jeff Blitz said the same thing to me when I was in the car with Oscar.
我说我爱德怀特。他说，安吉拉，此时此刻，表达你对这部剧和所有人的爱，如果你的生活中再也没有这一切了的话。然后我整个人就崩溃了。对啊。所以我在镜头前，打开了约翰写给我的这张便条，然后我就开始哭了。我就开始嚎啕大哭。这可能，第一条大概根本没法用。
And I say I loved Dwight. He said, Angela, in this moment, express your love for the show and everyone, and if you couldn't have it in your life anymore. And I disintegrated. Yeah. So I'm on camera, and I open up this note that John's written me, and I just start crying. I just start bawling. It probably, the first take was probably not usable.
那是最甜蜜的便条。而且你知道，在镜头前，帕姆说，我永远不会说上面写了什么，但只要知道那是完美的就行了。好吧，我永远不会说约翰具体写了什么，但我会说，只要知道那是完美的就行了。所以这就是茶壶便条里的内容，各位。那是约翰写给我的便条。是一张关于和我一起在这部剧里工作意味着什么的私人便条。对啊。对啊。
It was the sweetest note. And you know, on camera, Pam says, I'll never say what it said, but just know it was perfect. Well, I'll never say exactly what John wrote, but I will say just know it was perfect. So that's what was in the teapot note, guys. It was a note from John to me. A personal note about what it meant to work with you on the show. Yeah. Yeah.
关于我们在剧中共度的时光，真的很甜蜜。好吧，这绝对会把我彻底击溃。呀。哦，我太喜欢了。我之前不知道这个。你还好吗？好吧。真是糟透了。
About our time together on the show, and it was really sweet. Well, that would completely wreck me. Yeah. Oh, I love that. I didn't know that. Are you okay? Yeah. Well, crap.
还有什么特别美好的事吗？不好意思？那真的太美好了。我很喜欢那是格雷格给出的指导。在那种指导下，那些时刻对我们来说变得非常真实。对啊。而且我们都有过这样的小时刻。不过那真的是个非常大的时刻。
Is there anything else that was so beautiful? I'm sorry? That was so beautiful. I love that that was the direction that Greg gave. Those moments became very honest for us under that kind of direction. Yeah. And we all had little moments like that. That's a really big one, though.
好吧，剧里确实有那些出其不意的时刻。对啊。史蒂夫不知道我会跑过去告诉他基本上同样的话。史蒂夫，我会想念你的，你知道的，所有我对他说过的话。奥斯卡不知道杰夫·布里茨给我的便条。所以当所有这些情感涌现时，对他来说非常像，完全是突如其来的。对啊。
Well, there were those moments on the show that were surprises. Yeah. Steve didn't know I was going to run up and tell him that basically that same thing. Steve, I'm going to miss you, you know, all the things that I said to him. Oscar didn't know the note that Jeff Blitz gave me. Yeah. So when all that emotion came, it was very, like, completely out of nowhere for him. Yeah.
好吧，真是见鬼了。对不起。没关系。我们这集进展到哪儿了？好吧，我们到了凯特琳在厨房接近德怀特的时刻。凯利这个风骚的女人。哦！
Okay. Well, jeez, Louise. I'm sorry. That's okay. Where are we at in this episode? Well, we're at the moment when Kelly approaches Dwight in the kitchen. Kelly, that hussy. Oh!
她的头发半披半扎。我看到她走到我的男人面前，直接献上了一个吻。确实如此。安吉拉看到了，然后这就受够了。你知道，很多人写信来评论说，你当时正站在一张写着“承诺”的海报前面。我真的吗？是的。
With her hair half down, half up. And I know she goes up to my man and lays one on him. She does. And Angela sees it and that is it. You know, a lot of people wrote in and commented that you're standing in front of a poster that says commitment. Am I really? Yes.
哦天哪，我甚至都没注意到。太搞笑了。我想我当时太专注于这场戏了。好吧。哇。是的。安吉拉彻底失控了。彻底失控了。
Oh my gosh, I didn't even notice. That is so funny. I think I was just so focused on the scene. Yeah. Wow. Yes. Angela loses it. Loses it.
这把我们带到了室外。她离开了派对，现在我有些关于这场戏的事情要告诉大家。哦，对啊。好的。20分16秒。终极版安吉拉暴怒爆发了。所以这里有一些这场戏的幕后花絮。有个家伙在屋顶上，他手里拿着泡泡雪，会掉进
And this takes us outside. She's left the party and now I have some stuff to tell you guys about the scene. Oh yeah. All right. 20 minutes, 16 seconds. The ultimate Angela Pistofness has happened. So here's some behind the scenes of this scene. You have a guy up on the roof and he's got the soap snow that he's going to fall into
你的眼睛里。对啊。然后地上有雪，因为他们在地上铺了真雪。我们是在一天结束时拍这场戏的，大家都走光了。现场只剩下我和查尔斯·麦克道格尔、兰德尔·艾因horn以及迈克·舒尔。所以这时候基本上只剩一小撮核心工作人员了。那些一直是我最喜欢的拍摄时刻。对啊。
your eyes. Yeah. And then there's snow on the ground because they've put real snow on the ground. We filmed this scene at the end of the day and everyone had gone. It was just me and Charles McDougal, Randall Einhorn and Mike Schurr. So it was just a kind of a skeleton crew at this point. Those are always some of my most favorite shoots. Yeah.
我也是。而且我们没有多少时间。我们没有多少时间来搞定这个。时间一分一秒地过去。对啊。没错。因为我们不想让每个人都加班，而且已经是天黑收工的时候了。所以查尔斯·麦克道格尔对我说，我们大概只能拍两遍，
Me too. And we did not have a lot of time. We didn't have a lot of time to get this. The clock was ticking. Yeah. Exactly. Because we didn't want to go into overtime for everyone and it was the end of the day. And so Charles McDougal said to me, we're probably only going to do like two takes,
你知道的，也许三遍。没错。他们给了我这些饰品，给我的指导是我的角色已经彻底失控了。迈克尔毁了圣诞节。凯利吻了我的男人。瑞恩是派对策划委员会之王。啊！对吧？
you know, maybe three. Right. They gave me these ornaments and my instruction was that my character has just lost it. Michael has ruined Christmas. Kelly has kissed my man. Ryan is the king of the party planning committee. Ah! Right?
是的。他说，我需要你拿着这些饰品，直接把它们扔出去砸碎。剧本里写的是玻璃饰品。它们根本不是玻璃饰品。什么？看那场戏。我把它们扔下去。它们直接直挺挺地弹起来了。
Yes. He said, I want you to take these ornaments and just throw them and shatter them. They were written in the script as glass ornaments. They were not glass ornaments. What? Watch the scene. I throw them down. They were straight up in the air.
那是什么东西？它们某种塑料复合材料之类的。哦，不。所以当你看的时候，仔细看，各位。你能看到它们在空中弹起来。我想，好吧，这倒也合理。我们可没有预算去买那种特制的易碎玻璃饰品，他们绝对不可能给你真的玻璃。
What were they? They were like some kind of plastic composite, whatever. Oh, no. So when you look, watch it, you guys. You see them bounce in the air. I assumed, well, that makes sense. We did not have the budget to get special breakaway glass ornaments and there's no way they would give you real glass.
没错。所以这东西像网球一样弹了起来。于是查尔斯喊了“咔”，然后他说，好吧，两件事。好吧，我们需要你站得离墙更近一点。如果可以的话，在戏里尽量贴近墙壁，因为那是那个喷泡沫的人站的地方，泡沫掉不了多远。于是我们又拍了一条，他说，你怎么不把饰品砸碎？我说，查尔斯，它们在弹啊。
No. So these things bounced like a tennis ball. And so Charles is like, cut and he goes, okay, two things. Okay, we need you to stand closer to the wall. Like if you can in the scene, get as close to the wall as possible because that's where the guy is with the soap coming down, the soap doesn't fall very far. So we have another take and he's like, why aren't you breaking the ornaments? I'm like, Charles, they're bouncing.
你在说什么呢？他说，你能用力扔吗？我说，可以啊，它们只会弹得更高。然后我说，好吧，我明白了。我明白了。我有个主意。所以我现在知道我们真的时间不多了。所以，迈克尔·加伦贝格拍了一张最棒的照片，我手里有这张照片，画面是雪
What are you talking about? He goes, can you throw them harder? I was like, yeah, they're just going to bounce higher. And I was like, okay, I got it. I got it. I have an idea. So I know now we're really running out of time. So and Michael Gallenberg had taken the most awesome photo that I have and it's the snow
落下来，我正在扔饰品，而查尔斯·麦克道格尔在远处看着我。哦，太酷了。太棒了。迈克尔·加伦贝格，我们的布景设计师。是的。他拍了这张照片。太酷了。
falling and me throwing the ornaments and Charles McDougal in the distance watching me. Oh, cool. That's great. Michael Gallenberg, our set designer. Yeah. He took this photo. It was so cool.
不管怎样，我在这儿。我们时间不多了。我得站好。我得走到墙边去。我得把这些饰品扔出去，我需要它们砸碎，而且我得尖叫，对吧？所以我用，我说，我这次要更用力地扔。不知道。所以我用尽全力把它们扔了出去。
But anyway, here I am. We're running out of time. I got to stand. I got to get myself to the wall. I got to throw these ornaments and I need them to break and I have to shriek, right? So I throw them with, I said, I'm going to throw them harder this time. I don't know. So I threw them as hard as I could.
它们弹得更高了。我尖叫着，然后开始用脚狠狠地踩它们，把它们踩碎。你当时进去的时候就是这么打算的吗，心里想着“我有个主意。我能行。我能行”？我当时想的是，如果我没法把它们砸碎，我就得开始踩碎它们。是的。所以我刚才就是这么做的。
They bounced up higher. I shrieked and I just started stomping on them and shattering them with my feet. Was that your intention going in when you're like, I have an idea. I can do it. I can do it. I was thinking if I can't get them to break, I have to start stomping on them. Yes. So that's what I just did.
那完全是当场即兴发挥。我只是开始踩它们，大家注意到我穿的是我的时髦鞋了吧。哦，那简直是这场戏的最佳配鞋。我知道。所以我尖叫。我走到墙边。我踩着东西。我把盒子撕碎了。
That was just an improv in the moment. I just started stomping on them, folks notice I'm wearing my sass shoes. Oh, that's the perfect shoe for this. I know. And so I shriek. I get to the wall. I'm stomping things. I ripped the box apart.
我们拍到了这场戏。哦，我告诉你们，Tone Loc 89一定会非常高兴，因为他们发来了一个粉丝问题。是什么？我最喜欢的场景之一就是安吉拉尖叫并砸碎玻璃饰品的那段。拍摄过程是怎样的？就那些。是的。
We got the scene. Oh, let me tell you, Tone Loc 89 is going to be very happy because they wrote in with a fan question. What was that? One of my favorite scenes is when Angela screams and smashes the glass ornaments. What was it like to film? All of that. Yes.
完全正确。但现在如果你回去重看这场戏，大家看看我扔的前两个。我觉得那大概是第一条的镜头。它们直直地往上弹。所以当我们回到办公室时，我必须指出，当所有人决定去“可怜的理查德”酒吧时，迈克尔被邀请了，他脸上的表情，比他能收到的任何礼物都好。我知道。
Exactly. But now if you go back and watch the scene, you guys watch like the first two that I throw. I think that's kind of from the first take. They bounce straight up. So when we go back up in the office, I have to point out that when everybody decides to go to poor Richard's, Michael gets invited and the look on his face, it's better than any gift he could have been given. I know.
这就是那个时刻，你会觉得，迈克尔整集都混蛋透顶。然后你看到了这样一个悲伤、受伤的人，他只是想让别人喜欢他。没错。他有多么需要别人邀请他去喝一杯，或者他多么需要这个，或者他需要自己的礼物是最受欢迎的。他需要这种认可。好吧，我们在最后有迈克尔的采访镜头，他谈到了圣诞节和
And this is that moment where you're like, Michael has been just such a jerk this whole episode. And then you see this sort of sad wounded person that just wants people to like him. Yes. How much he needs people to invite him to have drinks or he needs it or he needs his gift to be the most popular. He needs that acceptance. Well, we have Michael's talking head at the end where he's talking about Christmas and
礼物。这里有个有趣的小花絮。这个采访镜头最初是拍摄放在剧集开头的。但他们在剪辑时把它放到了最后，因为格雷格想要做一个场景的混剪，以及人们离开、我们在停车场雪地里的画面。他说，哦，等等，那个采访镜头。那样用简直完美，因为有些事情是我们做不到的，因为纪录片风格，你不能用一首歌来做混剪。
gifts. Here's a little fun tidbit. This talking head was originally shot to be at the beginning of the episode. But when they were editing, they put it at the end because Greg wanted to do kind of a montage of scenes and of people leaving of us out in the snow in the parking lot. And he was like, oh, wait, that talking head. That works perfectly because something that we couldn't do because the documentary style, you couldn't do a montage with a song.
没错。你们的混剪都是配着采访镜头的。我们确实有过配歌的混剪，但那是车里在放歌的那种。当然。诸如此类的。那必须是声音，他们管那个叫什么，像现场音和现场音。对啊。诸如此类的。
No. You had montages were set to talking heads. And we have had a montage with song, but it's like the song playing in the car. Sure. Something like that. It has to be sound that is what do they call that like, like a live sound and a live sound. Yeah. Something like that.
现场原音。对啊。在我们进入本集的最后几个场景之前，我只想指出两句被粉丝奉为本集他们最喜欢的经典台词。哦，是的。说出来听听。一句是“耶稣，生日快乐。抱歉。
Active sound. Yeah. Before we get to the final scenes of the show, I just wanted to point out two lines that fans have quoted as some of their favorite lines ever in this episode. Oh, yes. Say them. One is happy birthday, Jesus. Sorry.
你们的派对太逊了。”是的。另一个粉丝最爱是“‘洋基换宝’就像马基雅维利遇见圣诞节”。我真的希望大家去看看这一集的DVD删减片段。顺便说一句，我们说这个可没拿广告费。我们真没有。我们只是觉得它们真的很好。我们真的觉得它们很好。
Your party is so lame. Yes. And another fan favorite is Yankee Swap is like Machiavelli meets Christmas. And I really do want you guys to check out the DVD deleted scenes from this episode. By the way, we're not getting paid to say that. We're not. We just really think they're good. We just really think they're good.
各位，奥斯卡·努涅斯在肢体喜剧方面太棒了。在拍《办公室》几年前的二十多岁时，我和他一起做过一个小品秀。我们认识很久了。他是个很棒的肢体喜剧演员，但他在《办公室》里没怎么有机会展现这一点。不过删减片段里有一场戏，他和克里德搬一张桌子，结果他被桌子给夹住了。他得从被卡住的地方脱身，真的，真的超级好笑。我想看那个。
You guys, Oscar Nunez is so great with physical comedy. I did a sketch show with him before the office years ago in my twenties. We've known each other forever. He is a great physical comedian, but he didn't get to do very much of that on the office. But there is a scene in the deleted scenes where him and Creed move a desk and he gets pinned in by the desk. He has to get out from being stuck and it's really, really funny. I want to see that.
而且菲莉丝在这集的删减片段里透露了她是怎么遇到鲍勃的。哦，她说他们相遇是因为他在隔壁上班。哦，好吧，原来如此。他们当时就在彼此旁边。而且凯文还有一整段说唱。他会说唱。哦，整整一段歌曲。所以如果可以的话，一定要去看看这些删减片段。
And Phyllis reveals in a deleted scene for this episode how she met Bob. Oh, she says that they met because he works next door. Oh, well, there you go. They were right there together. And Kevin has a whole wrap. He wraps. Oh, a whole portion of a song. So really check out these deleted scenes if you can.
它们太精彩了。好了。我们来聊聊办公室里面的最后一场戏。好的。发生在迈克尔的办公室里。他正准备离开。他要下楼去。梅雷迪思径直走进他的办公室，脱掉了上衣，然后史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔
They're fantastic. All right. Let's talk about the final scene inside the office. All right. It happens in Michael's office. He's getting ready to leave. He's going to go downstairs. Meredith just walks into his office, takes off her top, and then Steve as Michael takes
拍了张照片，然后走了出去。我有一个粉丝问题。好吧，首先，凯特，我真的很希望凯特能为这一期连线。我和她发过短信，但她要开始和《与星共舞》一起巡演了。哦，对啊。她今天在旅行。她在飞机上，前天晚上她给我打电话。她说，安吉，真的很抱歉。
a picture and then walks out. I have a fan question. Well, first of all, Kate, I really wanted Kate to be able to call in for this one. I traded text with her, but she is starting a tour with Dancing with the Stars. Oh, yeah. And she's traveling today. She's on a plane and she called me night before last. And she was like, Angie, I'm so sorry.
我没法连线，但她接着说，我真的很想来聊聊关于梅雷迪思的一切。所以她最终还是会来的。哦，那太好了。我有一种感觉，你可能知道这个粉丝问题的答案。好的。嘉莉·沙布说，或者可能是嘉莉·沙贝，说，当角色向彼此闪露身体时，演员们在现实生活中真的互相暴露了吗？
I can't come in, but she was like, I really do want to come in and talk about all things Meredith. So she will come eventually. Oh, that's good. I have a feeling you might know the answer to this fan question. Okay. Carrie Shab said, or maybe it's Carrie Shabe, said, when characters flash each other, are the actors really flashing each other in real life?
不，不，不。不。不。我是说，某种程度上。某种程度上。我是说，还是会尴尬的。哪怕我必须，比如说，穿泳衣，我也会觉得别扭。你知道我的意思吗？
No, no, no. No. No. I mean, sort of. Sort of. I mean, it's still embarrassing. Even if I had to, like, be in a bathing suit, I'd feel awkward. You know what I mean?
对啊。凯特当时贴了乳贴。凯特她。她算是被遮住的。对啊。她的私密部位贴了东西。对啊。史蒂夫真是个绅士。
Yeah. Kate was wearing pasties. Kate had. She was kind of covered. Yeah. She had things over her hoo-has. Yeah. Steve is such a gentleman.
他说，凯特，我只会看着你的脖子。对啊。盯着你的锁骨。对啊。里面没有任何剧组人员。没错。她的影像当时没显示在任何监视器上。没错。
He said, Kate, I'm just going to look at like your neck. Yeah. Stare at your clavicle. Yeah. They had no crew inside. Yep. Her image wasn't on any monitors anywhere. That's right.
而且数码相机里根本没有存贮卡。所以快闪光灯一闪。看起来像迈克尔在拍照，但实际上根本没拍过照片。从来没有拍过照片。所以他们在那个时刻对凯特的保护非常非常周到。凯特后来作为梅雷迪思还脱过很多次衣服。而且相当多。相当多。
And there was no chip in the digital camera. So the flash goes off. It looks like Michael's taking a picture, but there was actually never a picture taken. Never a photo. So they were very, very mindful of taking care of Kate in that moment. Kate would go on as Meredith to take off her clothes. And quite a bit. Quite a bit.
我最喜欢的一件事是，凯特的父亲亲手给她写了一封手写信。哦，天哪。信上写的内容很简单，这是她父亲写的，你知道的，凯特来自宾夕法尼亚州。信上只写着：亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。爱你的爸爸。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。凯特当时怎么做的？
One of my favorite things is that Kate's father wrote her a handwritten letter. Oh, my goodness. And all it said, this is her father, who, you know, Kate is from Pennsylvania. And all it said was, dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Love dad. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. What did Kate do?
她是怎么回应的？她当时的反应是，哦，天哪。那么，那是她爸爸在幽默搞笑，还是他真的在说“说真的，别再这样了”？我觉得两者都有。我觉得两者都有。好了。我们该聊聊停车场了吗？
How did she respond to that? She was like, oh, man. Now, is that her dad having a sense of humor or is that him being like, seriously, stop it? I think both. I think both. All right. Should we talk about the parking lot?
对啊。我们这部分快结束了。我们来聊聊停车场，因为这绝对是我在拍完整整九年里记得的最神奇的时刻之一，我们所有人都这么说。对啊。人们经常问，比如说，你最喜欢哪场戏？这总是很难解释，因为有时你最喜欢的戏，看起来并不是那么激动人心的一场戏，但正是幕后发生的事情让它成了你的最爱。
Yeah. We're almost done here. Let's talk about the parking lot because it is definitely one of the most magical moments that I remember in filming all nine years, and we all say that. Yeah. People often ask, like, what were your favorite scenes? And it's always hard to explain because sometimes your favorite scene, it doesn't seem like that exciting of a scene, but it's what happened behind the scenes that make it your favorite.
而这个停车场场景就是我最喜欢的场景之一。绝对是的。绝对是的。好了。所以今天，地上有这么多的真雪，每个人都要离开了，大家情绪都很好。而且真的是夜晚。我们很少在下午6点以后工作，所以我们总是很兴奋。
And this parking lot scene is one of mine. Definitely. Definitely. Okay. So today, we have all of this real snow on the ground, and everyone is leaving, and everyone's in good spirits. And it's really nighttime. It was really rare for us to ever work past 6 p.m., so we always got excited.
我觉得走到黑暗中，我们都觉得自己像是过了睡觉时间还在熬夜。但还有，你们得记住，这里是洛杉矶。地上从来不下雪。所以这本身就很神奇，我们的停车场积满了雪。当我们走向汽车时，我不知道，就像你看到的那个镜头，我其实坐在一辆SUV的前排乘客座上，但我只进去了半个身子，车门还开着。但我记得其中一个家伙抓起一把雪朝另一个人扔去。然后他们所有人都开始抓起雪，打起了这场即兴的雪仗。
To walk out in the dark, I think, we all felt like we were up past our bedtime. But also, you have to remember, this is Los Angeles. There's never snow on the ground. So this is magical in itself, that we have a parking lot full of snow. And as we're walking to the cars, I don't know, like, the shot you see, I'm actually in the front passenger seat of an SUV, but I'm only half in, like, the door's open. But I remember one of the guys just picked up some snow and flung it at the other one. And then they all started picking up snow and having this impromptu snowball fight.
每个人都很喜欢，他们希望我们继续玩下去。但那感觉就像是我们所有人一起在雪地里闲逛。我们变成了一群孩子。我们克制不住自己。对啊。我们过了睡觉时间还在熬夜，地上还积着雪。地上铺着新鲜的雪。真的太好玩了。
And everyone loved it, and they wanted us to keep doing it. But it was just sort of like us just all hanging out in the snow. We turned into a bunch of kids. We couldn't help it. Yeah. We were up past our bedtime with snow on the ground. Fresh snow on the ground. It was so fun.
而且你知道，我有一张我们所有人一起在停车场和查尔斯·麦克道格尔的合影。那张照片太棒了。我太喜欢了。我把它奉为宝贝。我太喜欢了。我想看。对啊。好吧，这就是为什么我们得做我们的剪贴簿小册子，安吉拉。
And you know, I have a picture of all of us together in the parking lot with Charles McDougal. And it's great. I love it. I covet it. I love that. I want to see it. Yeah. Well, this is why we have to make our scrapbook thingy, Angela.
我们确实应该做。我们应该把东西合并起来。好吧，这就是我们需要做的。我们应该把我们所有的东西堆在一起合并，然后把它做好，这样我们俩就能拥有我们各自所有的东西。对啊。对吧？对啊。
We do. We should combine. Well, that's what we need to do. We should pile and combine all our stuff and then make it so that we can both have what we both have. Yeah. Right? Yeah.
对啊。在我们把它们全弄丢之前，我们得把这事办了。好吧。现在是2020年。我们得把这事办了。这是我们今年的目标。我正在给我们定下今年的目标。好吧，各位，她都这么说了。
Yeah. Before we lose it all, we need to do it. Okay. It's 2020. We need to do this. This is a goal for this year. I'm setting the goal for us this year. Well, you guys, she said it.
现在我感觉，珍娜要开始严格督促我了。这一集真的很特别。确实很特别。我们真心希望我们没有辜负它，因为它对我们意义重大。这些剧集对我和其他人来说几乎比其他集更难拍，因为里面倾注了太多情感。场景中发生了太多事。不仅对我们个人而言很特别，而且对我们的角色来说也是一个重大时刻。
Now I'm like, Jenna's going to put me to task. This episode was really special. It was. We really hope we did it justice because it means so much to us. These episodes are almost harder for me than other ones because there's so much emotion attached to it. There's so much that happens in the scene. Not only like, is it special to us personally, but it was like a big moment for our characters.
而且就在最后那个时刻，那场雪仗，那正是一群彼此相爱的人聚在一起闲逛。而我们恰好一起拍了一部电视剧。对啊。这真的是一个非常特别的时刻。我太喜欢他们让它以这种方式结束了。这确实就是我们离开这部剧时的真实感受，我们只是一群恰好一起拍了一部电视剧的朋友，因为我们，我们就是朋友。
And just that moment at the end, that snowball fight, that is just a group of people who love each other, who are all getting to hang out. And we just happen to be on a TV show together. Yeah. It's just a really special moment. And I love that they let that be how it ended. And that's really how it felt when we left this show, that we were just a bunch of friends who happened to be on a TV show together because we, we were friends.
而且我们一直是朋友。对啊。我们是一家人。我们确实是。所以下周，我们还有另一集重磅剧集，安妮。超级重磅的一集。我是说，听着，第二季剩下的这几集，绝对会是一集比一集更重磅。
And we are friends. Yeah. And we're family. We are. So next week, we've got another big episode, Ann. Huge episode. I mean, we, listen, the rest of this season two is just going to be one momentous episode after the other.
接下来是《乘船游》，我们的特邀嘉宾是美国办公室的创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格·丹尼尔斯要来做客。我们超级兴奋。对啊。我们已经迫不及待想跟他聊聊了。提前谢谢你，格雷格。而且《乘船游》绝对是超级超级重磅的一集。我们下周见。
Next up is Boo's Cruise with our special guest, creator of the American office, Greg Daniels. Greg Daniels is going to be here. We are super excited. Yeah. We cannot wait to talk to him. Thank you, Greg, in advance. And Boo's Cruise is a huge, huge episode. We'll see you next week.
拜拜。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。若想收听无广告版的节目以及我们的彩蛋花絮，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Irwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。如需收听无广告版本的节目以及我们的独家彩蛋糖果包，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。